Sure.
Sam bitches.
I don't hear shit.
Oh,
I don't even have my,
that's how high was what happened.
I don't even have the
headphones on my ears.
And I'm like,
why am I not hearing anything?
Meanwhile,
they're pressed up against
the top of my head.
What the fuck dude?
Really after all these years,
that's how you roll in it.
And when Eddie Bravo is here,
that's embarrassing.
When you do like some serious stoner
shit and everybody knows you're a stoner,
you're like God dammit.
Yeah.
Fucked up one for the cause.
The show Rogan experience
is brought to you by,
this episode is brought to
you by audible.com and a
audible.com has this thing
that I've been raving about because it's
one of the coolest ideas that I've ever
heard,
uh,
in technology when it comes to
a audio books and audio podcast,
what they've done is they've
created something that's
an app for the kindle fire
and it really is worth
getting it just for this.
Uh,
it's,
it's an amazing application.
What it does is it allows you,
if you're a book reader,
I have,
um,
I have a kindle and I also have
a nook and they're both great.
But the difference between this kindle
fire thing is you can be reading the book
and you when you like you're
going to bed at night,
you could shut it off and it
will sync with your smart phone.
And then when you get in your car,
you hear the audio version of the book.
It's fucking incredible.
And it's,
it's done by professional actors.
So it's like a really good audio companion
book to the original book that you
can,
so you can either read it or listen to it,
which is a fucking brilliant.
I think that's like one of the
coolest inventions I've ever heard of.
I got a question now.
Yeah,
go ahead.
If you listen to a lot of books,
you know what I mean?
Can you still say you read a lot?
That's a good question.
That's a very good question.
Yes.
Yeah.
I don't know if you can.
Good.
It's close.
It's close,
but it's probably not the same.
There's probably something involved.
And actually reading the words yourself.
Yeah.
It seems more prestigious,
right?
That you actually read it yourself.
Yeah.
Is that more prestigious?
Says it's a little boring.
Boring.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I've definitely think
there's something too for a
reading as opposed to watching TV.
Like I find that people who read
more than they watch TV generally,
they have more interesting
shit to talk about.
Yeah,
they trust.
They trust a type letters
and sentences on paper.
More than like visual evidence.
It's kind of weird.
Like I read it,
I read it.
It means more because someone
typed it out like that.
People don't lie and fuck up reports
and fuck up all these different studies.
I thought we're talking about books.
Oh Shit.
I'm sorry.
I'm,
I'm standing up for the people that listen
to books because I think I'm going to
get into listening books.
I don't have time to read.
God Damn.
I don't have it is easy.
There's
a lot of shit you can listen to it.
audible.com you can listen to lectures
and the standup comedy podcasts,
they have everything.
What's the matter?
Oh,
I thought you said something.
Um,
anyway,
it's,
it's a kindle is a,
is an awesome tool and this,
um,
whisper sync that links up with
audible.com is just brilliant.
It's just unbelievable.
It's such a,
it's such a great application.
Uh,
audible.com is a offering.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you can get one free
audio book and 30 days,
uh,
free,
of service for from audible,
but to really,
uh,
an excellent service and a
big supporter of podcasts.
We're also brought to you by onnit.com
if you haven't been to on it in a while.
And you know,
we used to just sell
vitamins and nutrients,
which we still do,
but we sell a lot of other cool shit too,
which w what we've started doing is
just all the shit that we find out about
that's really good.
We just start selling it like,
like blenders.
Like I would always talk about Kale
shakes cause I drink them every morning.
I,
it's,
it's one of the best things I've ever
done as far as like health to give me
energy.
I feel fucking great when I have these
big Kale shakes and it just filled with
nutrients and vitamins.
It just really feels good.
Like I feel physically better.
It's no doubt about it.
There's garlic in it and ginger in it.
So we just started selling these blenders.
Sally's BLENDTEC blenders,
they're,
they're fucking bad ass.
Uh,
I had a Vitamix before that.
Pretty fucking good too.
The difference is the
BLENDTEC really like,
makes it like almost everything
turns it really liquidity.
Whereas the Vitamix,
so it's,
there's a little more chewy to it,
but either way,
both of them are great.
We sell the blend tax.
We also sell kettlebells
now and battle ropes,
kettle bells and battle ropes.
Have you ever seen like
a rapes battle ropes?
They ever seen?
Like any of those?
Um,
countdown to UFC shows where guys
are doing strength and conditioning.
A lot of times you see them whipping
these big heavy marine ropes.
They look like,
you know,
the ropes that you would
use to tie up boats.
And that's actually exactly what they are.
And that's actually exactly
where we get them there.
They're fucking bad ass.
It's a wicked workout.
It's a,
it's great for your cardio,
your shoulders,
it works,
your core,
everything works.
It's like real functional
strength Type Shit.
That's what we're selling.
We're also selling the best
supplements we can find.
The best things we can sell you.
Anything that we find that we
find personally beneficial.
A lot of these things
are very controversial,
especially the idea of a nootropics,
which are vitamins and nutrients that
you take to enhance brain function.
And there's a lot of debate on that man.
There's a lot of people
that don't believe in it.
that try and say they don't,
they don't experience anything but
every single aspect of Alpha brain,
all the different ingredients have been
closely studied by people for years.
Um,
there's actually a whole page
of the science behind it.
Um,
we have,
uh,
altered and improved.
The formula now was,
there was people that were
having like issues with Coleen.
It's a very strong tropic
and it really does,
in my opinion,
dramatically affect cognitive function.
I think that you're,
you just need a certain amount
of nutrients to get shit done.
And they have isolated
the best nutrients for,
uh,
for optimum use of the mind.
And uh,
it's very controversial.
And because of that,
we offer 30 pills.
The first 30 pills,
pills,
the order with any of the supplements,
you get a 100% money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the product.
The,
the reason behind that is twofold.
One,
because nobody is trying to rip you off.
If I didn't believe in this shit as
Eddie Bravo yawns down to like one of my
best commercials ever,
and you beyond all your commercials
that all guns that they all suck,
but we've got to get through folks,
go get some Alpha brain.
That's the point.
You get your money back.
You don't even have to return the product.
And you know what?
I take that shit.
I take Alpha brain and the shroom tech.
As a matter of fact,
I'm out.
I need some more.
I've got some of my hair which
going up that room as a whole box.
I take it every day.
I believe it works,
man.
I,
you know,
I know you wouldn't.
I mean you've done more
research into those ingredients.
And I have,
and I'm a supplement from lake,
you know me,
I'm weighing to vitamins and shit.
I take more vitamins and minerals and
most people I know it's not going to turn
a dumb person to a brilliant person,
but what,
what it's going to do is it's going to
give your brain the resources it needs to
produce smoother thoughts,
if that makes any sense to leave it.
I believe in it too.
Shroom tech sport is another fantastic
supplement that an endurance supplement.
It's all based on the core steps.
Mushroom.
Again,
if you'd go to [inaudible] dot com all
of this shit is explained ad nauseum.
You dirty pitches.
All right,
that's it.
This weekend,
this Friday night,
Brian motherfucking red ban,
Dunkin motherfucking Trussell and I
will be at the Moody Theater in Austin,
Texas.
Holla at your boy.
Um,
I don't think this may tickets left.
It's almost sold out.
But uh,
we're,
we're fitting to get
down Texas style or B.
All right,
let's cue the music man.
Fucking any problems here,
dude.
Explore.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
we do
plugs into the flood so the computer can
play through that soundboard out burnt
out.
Why you are echoing son?
I'm echoing.
I'll go is fuck you don't hear that
now say you sounded like a robot.
You were like an old
school Peter prepping song.
It's gone now.
Peter Frampton.
Let's see the first guy to ever use that.
That voice thing brought up on the like
I have a tube in their mouth and they
sing through it.
I don't know if he's the first guy.
Scorpions did that too.
Um,
when was Frampton wasn't even
before Scorpions forms the square.
That's like a harmonica thing.
I really don't know what the
fuck it is to tell you the truth.
I know it's smeared musician.
We might as well bring out a Kazoo.
What the fuck are you
doing with your mouth?
You know what it may be the songs
that I heard of them sucked anyways,
even without the Kazoo,
cause I don't like most songs so I,
I don't like most harmonica,
but what I do can really walk a harmonica.
It's pretty bad.
And we had that less shroud.
You know,
survivor man plays the shit
out of a harmonica that do,
it plays the shit out of a harmonica.
He does that shit all
day when he's going to
practice better.
He ain't got no berries to eat.
There's no face.
He's a bad ass.
My
Monica player,
man,
I was,
I was really touched yet.
He's legit mean.
But if your dorm,
old normal harmonica songs,
get the fuck Outta here,
bitch.
You're not making enough noises.
It's gotta be on top of like
some deep ass awesome music.
Yes.
You know,
I don't know.
Yeah.
It's kind of be like a compliment to
some like dope southern guitar music,
you know?
Then it could see a little
harmonica moving in.
Deliverance.
Dueling Banjos,
a little banjos,
little banjos ain't bad man.
This,
this,
um,
new band that I just
found out about called um,
uh,
fuck.
Go something roadkill.
Jesus Christ.
Ghost wrote roadkill goes choir.
I think it's the name of it.
Yeah.
Let me,
let me find out because
I feel like a Douche bag.
I said your words.
Have you been hanging out?
Shut up.
So my own,
my own.
God Damn it,
Dude.
I'm telling you.
It's a fucking Badass band.
Roadkill.
Ghost choir.
Listen,
put up.
Put,
pull this up.
Can we,
can we play music?
Pull up a sure.
I was freaking out as
good as it normally would.
Okay.
There's a song called
beggars guild and it's like,
it's got like a little
a banjo thing to it.
Dude.
It's a dope fucking song.
I played this song like a hundred times.
I don't know if you're going
to be into it and I'm curious.
That's why I want to play it for him.
Wrote a house on the spine.
Road kill ghost choir.
Oh,
you don't want to be put on the spot it,
let's hear it.
I'm curious now he and I,
but I love Eddie Bravo to death.
Okay.
He is my brother.
I don't like most.
We have totally different tastes in music.
I don't like most music.
I have totally different
tastes in everybody.
Everybody.
I don't like very much music.
You know,
when I was a kid I
couldn't accept that shit.
I didn't like when
people didn't like shit.
You got to understand.
I deejayed at a strip
club for holding years,
beggars guild.
That shit.
I got music eight hours a day,
sash nonstop.
That was no breaks.
There's no break.
You've got to pay for the
next lap dance a motherfucker.
That's about it.
You got really bored with
Whitesnake after how many
girls came out?
Oh look,
that was before the show.
That was,
that was 87.
I didn't start tag until like 93,
but that song hung around.
It's true a little bit by that time.
Uh,
there's only like one metal chick per
strip club and she plays some Whitesnake,
but most of the girls were
playing what was modern,
what was had they were playing like
stone temple pilots or nine inch nails or
Madonna.
I got all in Manson.
I got in a car accident and uh,
I got in a car accident with this girl
that I was dating and she was like super
melodramatic man.
She was hilarious.
But,
uh,
when,
this old dude ran a light and hit us and,
uh,
I had to take my shit out of my car
because I couldn't drive my car.
And in my car,
I had a white snake cassette
and she picked it up.
She goes,
you have to throw this out.
She made me throw out a
white snake cause this is it.
This is them.
Listen to this band,
man.
That was funny.
Tell me if you like these people
smelly.
She's not getting the full effect
of the base in this two things.
Once the light,
the live performance and the,
I like it though.
I like this guy's got him
fucking hypnotic voice man.
Okay.
No,
I'm not doing this song
justice by lending to it.
Like I do like this.
You gotta you gotta listen to their,
uh,
their studio version of it.
It's fucking great man.
Whew.
What a song,
man.
I like it.
I could tell it's good.
Yeah.
I'm a,
I'm a fan of like dudes
who play like what?
I love to hear the guitar,
you know,
I'd love to hear the drums.
I love to hear Shit.
You,
you're in like cool,
like electronic type music and everything.
That's good.
And if you listen to my music,
it's a little of everything.
There's not,
I mean,
there's a little metal,
there's little Edm,
there's little dubstep,
whatever the latest,
she would never like.
Listen to a led Zeppelin album,
you know what?
And led Zepplin has about
five songs and I really liked,
but overall,
overall,
you know,
like stairway to heaven,
it's a great song.
All right,
that's a great song.
I'll ramble on.
Fucking great.
So there's a couple legs up and stuff,
but most of my misty mountain
high and rock and roll,
whatever.
Most of it was on the boogie tip.
I wasn't on the boogie tip.
It's like Boogie rock with a,
with a lot of blues and shit really.
And hours into a kiss and kisses,
more like anthems and,
and,
and more.
Um,
it just was the kissing.
I was on that side.
I was,
I was on the kiss side.
I wasn't on the led Zeppelin side.
It was a,
but I respected the shit out of him.
But,
uh,
I just was a kiss fucking freak dude.
I was so poor.
Really.
I didn't have enough money to be
into more than one band at a time.
So I chose kiss and I dove in
and by the time I got into kiss,
they already had like
eight albums and shit.
I had,
I got a dollar a week.
I'm like,
that's a lot of fucking dollars.
I got save saved by these kiss albums.
There were six 99 at the post.
Crazy that at one point in time you
used to have to pay to get some music.
That was the only way.
I mean,
boy,
did the fucking rug come
out of that business.
Yeah,
man had a lot of alums to catch up.
So I didn't,
I didn't have,
I didn't allow myself
to get into other bands.
To tell you the truth.
For a while,
from the age of eight to 13,
it was always just kiss.
I only can afford one band.
So I have a pretend like
I only liked one pen.
My brother could own everybody.
All my friends could only afford one band.
So my brother was in the van Halen.
Uh,
you know,
the Eric across the street was into rush.
Uh,
then this guy was in to the police,
you know,
and then we just borrowed each other shit.
But the band that you were in charge of,
that was your baby.
You know what I mean?
That's ridiculous.
It's crazy.
It's the stupidest shit ever.
What the fuck is wrong with children?
Oh.
And then we can go and kiss.
Got The sold out and it
became bubblegum ish.
They basically became Mc
Hammer of rock and roll.
That happened.
It started happening in [inaudible] 78.
They just got too big,
too commercial.
They did a movie on Channel Four and NBC
movie called Kiss meets the Phantom of
the park.
It was on contract.
It was out of control.
They were like superheros state dude.
I was severely depressed
because when it came on,
there was a blackout where I lived.
The fucking power was
out while kiss meets.
The Phantom was on TV and I was so
depressed and I couldn't believe it.
I'm like,
how the fuck could this happen?
Now that movie is what got me into kiss.
Cause before that movie,
the,
the general consensus among kids
at school was that kiss like,
cause they're older brothers will
telling him his kisses for homos.
So I remember being at school the
night it was supposed to be on being at
schools and talking to my friend saying,
are you going to watch that kiss movie?
They're like,
no way.
Kisses for fags at eight
year olds were saying that,
you know.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
So,
and I was pretending like
I didn't like kiss either,
you know,
cause my Stepdad was into
classic rock and I would,
I would say like Ted Nugent or something.
You know what I,
I just,
yeah,
I'm into that.
You know,
I wasn't in the kiss,
but we were all excited
to see that kiss movie.
Kids didn't have risk and that was like
two 78 they didn't have respect for
kiss.
That's how they were going down.
They were just too commercialized.
That was kiss ice cream cause bubblegum
kiss pencils that were going down.
Nobody had any respect
for him at that point.
There were falling off
when I was in high school.
Like the dudes were like that.
I hung around with everybody
listened to like the doors
blend,
spectacle,
Mick kiss by the age of eight when
I was at you couldn't admit kiss,
but when that movie came on that night,
me and my brother was four years older.
We were so excited to see this
fuck this band that we were were,
we were already dissonant.
We didn't even see him.
But that movie blew me away.
Rock and roll all night.
When they played that shit on the
movie as an eight year old kid,
my head exploded.
All I wanted was rock and roll all night.
I was like,
Cartman Dragon.
His mom did the fucking record.
Still going.
Um,
I dragged my aunts.
I'm like,
rock and roll all night.
That's the one I want.
I'm,
we looked for it.
It was on kiss alive.
It was a live record.
I didn't know what a live record was.
So I just said,
this is the one that
says rocket all night.
This is the one.
And my aunt goes,
I think this is at a concert.
What are you talking about?
It's a record.
It's not a concert by the record.
Got The record,
played it,
put the needle down.
And when you hear the audience coming in,
like what the fuck is this?
It's a concert.
I was like,
I didn't even have,
I didn't know what a live record was.
I didn't understand just
the live too and kiss alive.
Three,
I got kiss alive one
that that was my first,
our first kiss record and that crushed me.
That album destroyed strutter dues.
Got to choose Rechis lives.
Yeah.
But by the,
by kiss alive three that was like already,
uh,
in the 90s,
dude when everything was dead because
the life they were shit I picked up with,
there's errors of kiss before
me that I didn't get into.
I never got into like the really early,
early,
early shit.
I came in around Detroit rock city.
I came in early cover when they were
on the cover of a double platinum,
no,
not double platinum.
What was the destroyer?
That was the first album after they're
live on the first three albums where
like,
uh,
failures and they weren't selling man.
And then they just said,
dude,
let's just try a live record
because live or killing it.
Everyone loves a slide,
but we can't sell any records.
Let's do a live record.
And they said,
okay,
let's try it.
They did it.
And that's the one that blew him up.
Kiss alive him the fuck up.
So destroyer was the first studio album
after this live record that blew him up.
Right?
What,
what bands out?
They'd get blown up
from their live records.
None of them that we're the only ones.
So fun though.
Yeah.
And they would live shows where like dad,
they look Paul Stanley,
you can make fun of like this.
There's dudes who have like
taken his all of his life,
the Star Child Center kiss Paul's
people have taken like his,
all of his in between stuff and
Rico and brought it to like one CD.
I forget the guys who did it,
but they sent it to me and
it's fucking hilarious.
It's brilliant.
They took a whole is best rants and hey,
I know like,
oh dude.
But he's a showman like a motherfucker.
I mean,
the place is going crazy
stories ready to go.
He had to love guns.
Story.
Every story had the cold Jin's story.
He,
every concert,
like there's three songs,
maybe two or three ways.
Got a story and he's
talking about it's so,
yeah,
it's such
a big show,
you know,
that went to see them.
I,
you know,
it was back when Gene Simmons
was still spitting fire.
Uh,
he's never stopped spinning
fire still does it,
you know,
you can easily,
when the makeup came off,
he still spitfire that shit.
He'll never stop doing that.
Cray did his hair ever catch on fire?
Caught on fire early in their career.
That's crazy.
And then ace got electrocuted by the
stair railing was to God Jesus Christ.
That's a crazy ass show,
man.
Yeah.
So that movie,
you know,
from that movie on,
I was a kiss fanatic and,
but I was getting into them.
Right.
We're never going down and had no respect.
But that's when I got into them
is when they lost all respect,
uh,
from the mainstream media
when it came to Iraq,
you know.
And so I had a fight with my friends.
Everyone's made,
made fun of me that I liked kiss.
I had a fucking,
there was a bunch of music that I had
to go back and sort of review cause I
dismissed it because it was all like
serious stoners that we're into it.
Like the doors is one of them.
I never was really adores person when
I was in high school because all the
people that were in the doors were
all fucking serious burnouts man.
Because you've got to think like that.
This was after like,
okay,
I was in high school in 1981 all right,
when did he die?
I don't do die like in the 70s I never
was adores fan girls who are still into
like Morrison like that late.
It's like they were like fucking,
they always had jean jackets on.
So he's cigarettes in their pockets.
Those had dirty hair and they
would just burnouts and that's,
so that's what I
associated with the doors.
Those are the people that always have the
door shirts and I had to like become a
man one day and become my own man and
listen and go God damn the towards had
some good fucking songs and
then I got into them afterwards.
So it's like the people that were so
into him sort of negatively affected my
opinion of him unfortunately.
Yeah,
you can never admit that you
would like certain bands though.
There are certain bands and if you
brought up that you were into a map,
people get angry.
I had to pretend it got so bad I had to
pretend for a while that I didn't like
kiss.
I'm like,
I don't like this anymore.
Goddammit.
I hate them.
I was in high school,
I was on a bus and I told this dude
that I was going to go see a cheap trick
were I was like,
cheap tricks come in town,
we'll go see cheap trick.
And this guy turned
around and looked at me.
It was meant cheap.
Chip fucking sucks.
And I remember like,
wow,
this guy totally just not
respect my taste in music.
He just shot it down.
I couldn't even say anything about it.
I was like,
well,
you know to you like the what you say
when someone just shits on you and then
even while you're there,
that can influence your
enjoyment of going to see it.
You know?
Because even though you're enjoying it,
you're like,
God damn it.
Like why does this band made me
feel like a loser for liking them?
Yeah.
The thing about the kiss
though that they've,
no one has ever done,
no one has ever done kids.
They went to superstardom.
Then they went to Mc Hammer status and
vanilla ice status and then they came
back and did it all over
again with the same members.
They got ace and Peter Back who ended up
getting kicked out for being drunks and
coke heads in the late
seventies in the height of it,
they kicked out their drummer,
they kicked out the guitar player,
got them replaced,
but when they did the
reunion tour 15 years later,
20 years later,
whenever the fuck it was,
they got ace and Peter Back and then
they blew up again and they took their
makeup off and then they put it
back on the most interesting.
Yes,
I left that part out.
You got during the reunion and when
they died they decided to take off their
makeup for about 10 years and
they went on and they were lost.
They didn't know how to dress dude.
They just looked at the
other bands and said,
you know what poison is there?
I guess the Tremie look is
in let's look like trannies.
I think that's what's in.
When we were in high school,
they would like,
they always had like Bandanas on and shit.
When they were going to clubs and stuff,
like they had to like hide their identity
and they'd get these photos of them
like trying to put a
palm up to the Presley,
couldn't get photographed like that
was the weirdest sort of celebrity ever
because these guys were superstars,
but nobody knew what they looked like.
I don't know if everybody today can
wrap their head around how fucking crazy
that shit was.
How crazy is that?
Come on there like late
seventies these dudes done that.
No one has that in music.
No one else has done the which
no one knows what you look like.
You,
we got to get pictures of you on man.
That shit was like CIA
secret shit right there,
dude.
They pulled that off from (970) 310-1983
were done 10 years for 10 years.
They had makeup.
You could only do that back then.
You could never get away
with that shit today.
There's too many people with cameras.
Too many people who put
that shit on Youtube,
you know?
They just know where Paul Stanley lives.
Just wait,
just wait.
Just wait.
Wait in front of his house,
you know,
they ain't put a camera
in front of his face.
There he is.
And then when they did it again,
when they blew up again,
ace and Peter got kicked out again
for the same shit and they really get,
they got kicked out again.
What happened?
They just got started going off rocks.
They're drunks and I think Peter was
just too old and he couldn't even play
anymore.
And they're like telling me,
well you know,
because because uh,
uh,
Paul Stanley isn't like marathon shape.
He's always been a workout
health free like his,
his body,
he's like very athletic and
he's like 60 something now,
you know,
65 and gene Simmons is not the
in the best shape but live.
He gives his his,
he loves being on stage so much that
every night Jean Simmons gives it 110%
every night.
He's on fire,
Dude.
He can't,
they won't stop touring
men or 68 years old.
How much do they love being on stage?
Paul Stanley and Gene Simmons,
they stayed together.
They never broke up.
They never quit.
They went through a lot of
guitar players and drummers,
a lot of them,
but it was always Peter or Paul and gene
sticking together with without makeup.
They never stop.
They never take took a break.
I still don't think
they feel like they get,
they're like just rewards or no,
cause every interview
you hear the bitterness,
every dogging on the media,
they're dogging on
journalists and they're,
they're reminding people,
you know,
you can't ignore the millions of fans.
You know,
just listen to the fans.
forget about they hate
journalists because you know,
they got,
they blew up without any radio airplay.
You couldn't even play
them on the fucking radio.
That's how taboo they were.
They did it without radio airplay,
but why wouldn't the radio recognize
how many people were coming to see their
concerts and buying their
albums and just play their shit?
That doesn't make any sense.
Like they're like,
we're not going to allow
these goofy clowns to just,
you can't look like a clown
and make rock and roll music.
They were just not allowing them.
They weren't allowing it.
That was it.
That must have been an incredibly
tough time to be an artist,
you know,
to,
to have to deal like only with record
companies and only with radio stations.
That's just a couple of decades ago.
Like what a weird world we live in
today where people get fame through
electronic means.
Like how many people like that Dj ts,
was that his name?
Yeah.
How many people have heard his shit
because it's been online or dead mouse or
enhance people?
All you could,
they could.
Those guys could become famous just
by virtue of their product and it's
spreading virally.
Yeah.
That,
that's what a shit time.
It must've been when that couldn't happen.
When you had to deal
with all these assholes,
it wouldn't play you on the radio.
And they're like,
what do you have to do?
How do you get played on the radio?
What do you have to do,
you know,
does connect with anybody,
play them?
It's not,
you know,
that that was,
there was,
it was very rare that you
heard a kiss song on the radio.
He would not.
They would not.
Uh,
well they,
they played hours made for
loving you a little bit.
They did play Bethlehem.
That was the disco era.
They went a little disco.
They said,
look it,
they thought they thought discos the new
thing and it's going to be the future.
So kiss,
they made a decision.
Paul and gene are businessmen.
They go with the trends
and sometimes it's,
it's,
it's obvious that we owe now,
oh,
you're going to go really
heavy on this album.
Why?
Cause everyone dogged you that
you went to commercial and disco.
Oh,
let's see.
Like the careers in the toilet,
they got to come back at me.
That's what they did and
creatures of the night,
you know,
it's,
their career is just fucking insane.
It's a crazy life to be a musician man,
to make noises that
people like to listen to.
That's what you do.
You put together words and he'd make noise
with your mouth and with some musical
instruments are professional
noisemaker what a crazy thing that is.
The,
the,
the beauty of music is so misunderstood.
It's so hard for us to wrap our heads
around what the fuck is really happening
when you're listening
to a song because it's,
there's something,
something happens to you,
like a real,
a good song like does fire
you up and make you feel good.
It gives you a charge.
You know,
there's certain times when you're in
your car and it's just the right song for
the right moment and you know,
like God damn,
this feels good.
And that's,
that's generally the way I feel that way.
What you're describing as when
I'm driving to go teach class,
when
I'm driving to teach class my,
I just took my glaucoma medication and
then I find just the best song that I
liked that song that I could put it on
repeat and I crank it really loud and I'm
thinking about training Jujitsu.
I'm like,
I'm driving and I'm going to go transcend
Jujitsu and all my boys that I love
are going to be right there and
we're all going to work together.
And when I get in that zone and I'm
listening to an an amazing song,
it's the craze.
It's man,
it's,
it really is like a meditative state,
like a waking meditative
state where you're,
you're like,
you feel connected to the universe.
Man.
I,
it's hard to explain,
especially while under the
influence of Glaucoma medication.
Yes.
Especially that.
And the best song if you've
got crazy and ate some,
yeah,
and you've got some love
that you're going to,
you're driving to and you got to just
people just driving from San Diego,
people drawn from Costa
Mesa just to train.
That's when I,
when I think about that
and how amazing that is,
man,
and how much love I'm
going to have at my gym,
man,
when I'm there.
That's,
it's,
it's amazing,
man.
I love being there.
Every night.
Songs have this weird effect on people,
man.
You know?
I wonder if it can be measured,
like the good feeling that you get
when you hear a bad ass fucking song.
Like for me it's like,
I know this song gets worn
out for a lot of people,
but for me,
the first few chords
of Sweet Home Alabama,
I always go,
fuck yeah.
Like I haven't loved that God damn song.
I don't,
I don't give a fuck of day
overplay that stupid song.
You can overplay that shit forever.
That's still is like one of my
all time favorites on the side.
If I'm in a car and it's a nice
day and that song comes on,
I'm like,
Oh shit and I'll turn that shit up.
Right when he says to turn it it,
boom,
boom.
It's just that feeling though.
I wonder if it can be measured.
I wonder if you could put like a
electrodes on your head and find out what,
what's,
what's firing up when you
really love to hear a good song,
they should do that and then she'd get
people high and make them listen to
awesome music and just find out what
happened and then in between that awesome
music,
throwing some bullshit.
So really whack ass,
terrible fucking music.
Some like really bad
Christian rock or something,
something,
something just terrible.
Did you read that there was something
on Twitter about some research done on
freestyle rappers and [inaudible]?
I did,
but I saw it,
but I didn't want you to read it,
so I saw it like as a headline.
There's this study and they studied
freestyle rappers and they put some
electrodes on their brain.
I'm not sure how it really worked,
but as they were,
they had him freestyle,
freestyle,
some stuff,
and then the,
I think they had him say some
letters that they knew before and,
and,
and see the difference in how the brain
works when you're freestyling and how
the brain works when you're
just repeating stuff.
Something like that.
I could be wrong,
but the old school,
the overall,
the overall of that was that freestyle
rappers are quicker thinkers.
I mean obviously like the obvious stuff
did look at their brain is working
faster than normal people.
Yeah.
They there.
Well,
the idea that you have to be creative,
you have to put yourself into that,
that mode.
What percentage of freestyle
rappers you think smoke weed?
I think it's 190
right?
Hasn't,
that's what I'm dying.
They didn't talk about
the weed connection.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
You're talking about freestyle rappers.
They're probably smoking weed all day,
stuffing their brain with it.
Well,
we had a mortal technique on his,
his dude,
Swayne.
Remember that dude,
Brian?
Yeah.
That guy was a bad mother
fucker and battle rap.
Like there's some dudes who have that
shit down to an art form and you watch
like one guy will come at them.
So I'm like really dumb shit.
And then they break them down.
But some just ruthless shit.
Those guys could freestyle their ass off
and they smoked the fucking shit out of
some ways.
It'd be cool if that shit was huge on NBC.
Joe,
when you sit 190%,
where you and counting goes faces.
Awesome.
Is that how you got to that number?
Yeah,
that's exactly it is.
And um,
you know,
multiple personalities to throw that in.
I was just exaggerating,
Brian.
That's all it is.
Uh,
Kevin,
uh,
on Carerra prairie show today,
somebody made a,
uh,
a hilarious video game.
Like,
this is a real video game based on,
uh,
an episode of the podcast we did with
bobcat and based on the dolphin sensation
and stuff,
like,
you're going to freak out.
And if you want to be an investor,
this,
me and Kevin are gonna Invest in this
game and tried to actually have this game
be like a huge game.
Well,
what the hell is it?
Check it out.
You're going to laugh your ass off.
Uh,
it's uh,
echo the reluctant dolphin
echo the reluctant
dolphin and it's a game.
There we go.
Echo the reluctant dolphin.
[inaudible]
I want you to on the screen.
Yeah.
It's a dolphin with a huge Boehner.
And on the bottom right you can see us,
it's frothy loads.
You go around shooting,
hiss on everyone in
fucking peep in the ass.
And then you also have a come meet.
Oh my God.
Hello.
And then here's a,
here's the logo for our podcast,
pointless with Kevin Pereira.
And those are Jesus's.
So you're this dolphin shooting,
come and kiss on people.
And he turned me.
Then Jesus comes out and
tries to fuck you up.
And then he's shooting comment.
Here's your fucking more,
there's Kevin prayer.
Wow,
please stop this before we go to jail.
That dolphins walking funny
cause you just got fucked.
I just had Deja Vu.
That dolphin was in prison.
Something about my brain.
His name
is,
uh,
hold on.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
His name is Tim e.
H invest in that shoe.
That's going to be huge.
I know it's going to be here.
Do you?
That could be the
greatest game of all time.
You want to really put
your money in that one,
Brian,
I'm going to be real with you.
I think that's going to,
cause that's going to be the final nail
in the fucking Jesus People's coffin
where they go straight Taliban on
people even draw Jesus anymore.
We're coming for you bitches.
It even has a a meter that says frosty
loads and then it also has coffee.
Rocky loads it and also has a gate meter,
but it's spelled with an h instead of gay.
Listen man,
you can't,
uh,
you can't be attached to that.
It's going down and it's going
to bring you do with with it.
I just want to say off the record,
uh,
if it had I known the
content of that video,
I wouldn't have allowed it to be played.
Dolphins can't fuck Jesus in my world.
I don't allow it.
Android.
Jesus.
I don't care where we can
call whenever you want.
That's he actually fucked Jesus.
No,
I think Jesus shows up.
Jesus.
You know what?
They were going to have him fuck Jesus,
but they thought,
you know,
dolphins are flush.
Try to get the video game
off the fucking ground.
Okay.
We don't need to go there.
This the second version,
you know,
we'll save it for them in
the video of the dolphins.
Fuck people.
You can't fuck people in videos.
I'm sorry.
You can't just run around.
He's in Lucky's house.
Terminator Jesus though.
Look,
and he has meant to us.
I watched the terminator the other day,
um,
and uh,
it was a terminator two and
it was really weird to watch,
man.
You know,
it's really weird.
Like how like kind of like the acting
style was like different back then.
Like the movies where
they just like they were,
they weren't as like evolved.
Which ones to the second one was the,
what was that?
The one where the dude has that?
The guns and roses one,
which was the guns and roses one to
two is when he returned and he was,
she was,
she was like in a mental
institution and shit.
Doing Chin ups.
Go on.
This mother fuckers coming
back Arnold when he was mean.
I liked it in the first one.
That's it.
Oh you mean like when he came back?
Nice.
I'm not into that.
I wasn't as good.
I liked the main one.
The main one was way scarier.
Look,
why would they have the same
model come back nice with the,
can't make a different model
and it's just so stupid.
It's the same model.
The first model was a motherfucker
finally seen a good movie.
Argo Dude.
I heard Argos.
Very good Argos.
Fucking good.
It was a really,
I thought I was reluctant to see it
cause I thought it was going to be like
contagion where it shows like that
our government is so good and with the
viruses and the vaccine,
it's like contagion was a joke.
It was almost like produced by the
CIA almost or FEMA or something.
It was weird but,
and I thought they were going to do
the same thing with article make the
Iranians look like just
fucking these evil Daryl is,
they want to make bombs
and shit like that.
But they told the truth.
They did in the beginning.
They set up,
I mean it in the beginning.
It makes the,
the United States look at fault for a
lot of the shit that's going on and it's
the truth and the movie itself is damaged.
It's pretty amazing man.
Wow.
Doing it.
That's a strong endorsement
by Young Eddie Bravo.
I usually hate movies but that one I
stayed for the movies and I love language
ones cabin in the woods.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
If you're going to try to be funny or
you're not going to be serious at better
be like real funny,
like funny,
funny,
not like you liked it.
It was beautiful.
Okay.
50 50 thing.
Like I get in my tweets,
people say I'm fucking crazy.
And then some people agree to me.
It was just exciting fun.
It was just ridiculous,
silly fun,
you know?
But I believe these fucking people have
a remote control and it can change the
house and make monsters and
Sigourney weaver at the end,
it was almost hilarious.
I Dunno,
I enjoyed the shit out of it.
It was campy to me.
Uh,
it was like intentionally campy.
I thought it was really good.
I enjoyed it.
But uh,
yeah,
it's hard.
It's hard to fucking
make a good movie dude.
I think,
I think got too many people involved.
I think when you got some bad
motherfucker like James Cameron,
that can just totally take the reigns.
That's how you get like an Avatar.
You got to have some like real
strong personality behind it.
That's why like it's always important,
like Francis Ford Coppola is this or that
because I think there's so many people
involved and poking and prodding and
wanting this and putting in that.
I think making a movie must be,
it's just a fucking tremendous nightmare.
It working with all those people
and hoping they work together.
I have a friend who's a,
a movie director and a cheesy,
if you ever met Patty,
uh,
Patty Jenkins,
Bryan County,
his ex girlfriend,
she's,
um,
great,
great person,
fucking really interesting chick,
really smart chick and
she's an it director.
So she tells me some fucking stories,
man.
The story she tells you about having
to work with like crazy actors,
people that are just not
people you never even heard of,
he's fucking out of their mind.
They just hold up production and go crazy
and claim fake illnesses and faint and
should do weird shit to get attention.
Like people are nuts.
So you got to bring all
these motherfuckers together
and try to put some movie
out of it.
So ridiculously hard proposition,
you know?
That's why I was,
I've always looked at bands,
you know,
I've always looked at bands like going,
that's got to be fucking hard thing
for all these guys to get along.
Oh Man.
You know.
See the guns,
just recently I saw the guns and roses
a behind the scenes of the behind the
music,
rocky mentoree and I
saw the quiet riot one.
You got to see the quiet riot one.
You'd got to see,
it's a,
the VH one behind the scenes
and the guns and roses.
When those guys,
the whole,
the whole documentary is about how
much party and never doing and how much
drinking and it was driving them insane
how much coke they were doing and
drinking two fifths of Jack every damn
like I duff from guns and roses are so
fucked up.
He couldn't even,
he couldn't even talk anymore.
The super rich,
they're huge and they're just
drinking and doing so much coke.
They're out of their fucking minds.
They,
it's almost like they,
they feel,
it's almost like you understand
axel axel like the Dick,
but when you watch the rocky Mentari he's
hanging out with these drunk dudes all
the time.
I don't know.
I don't,
I,
it's,
it's hard to tell who's really at fault.
Like axles,
the control,
Hungary,
a tyrant,
he wanted control of everything and
then everyone else is super drunk.
It's like you understand a little bit,
right?
It has,
it has to be so hard to keep all
those egos in check when they,
when they explode and get huge,
it's gotta be so hard,
especially for like certain
dudes like in the background,
like drummers and shit.
I was just not getting
that much attention.
Got to get crazy,
get into like Tommy Lee was one of the
few guys that got attention yet to be a
drummer and to have
people know who you are.
And your first and last name.
Randy Travis Barker.
Tommy,
Tommy Lee.
And that's it.
That's it.
It can't be Peter Criss.
Yeah.
Household names.
Tommy Lee is a household name.
So it was Travis bark.
Yeah.
Householding.
Everybody knows who it is.
Very few times.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's a weird spot,
man.
The celebrity drummer,
that's a rare spot.
Those might be the baddest
motherfuckers ever.
They shined through that position.
Tom.
Tommy Lee is a bad motherfucker.
Everybody just had to see his dick and go,
okay,
I gotta shut the fuck.
What are you going to say guys?
Guys are rock star and
he has a giant Dick.
That's it,
Dan.
He just kind of accept that
there's,
thank God he does.
He's not really good at Jujitsu Shit.
Ricky rocky.
Imagine if he was also really good.
A real good fighter too.
Shit.
Ricky rocket's a fucking black belt.
Yeah.
Legit black belt in Jujitsu.
Whoever thought that Ricky
rocket is the drummer of poison.
He's another one.
He's another famous one.
We missed him.
Famous trumped up there.
He's,
he's a household name.
If Ricky rocky went on a killing spree,
that shit would be front page news.
Yeah,
he's a good dude.
Yeah.
He seems like a nice guy.
Like you know,
I think that uh,
someone who gets really good at Jujitsu,
like you can't get that far without like,
he was super cool.
Super Cool.
Super Cool Guy.
Trained with them a lot,
hung out with them a lot.
We,
we both went to,
we all went to the same school.
It was really,
really super cool and it was a,
it was a trip to see,
you know,
so much,
he was like in a band
it's known to look like,
you know,
like they look like girls
that have lots of makeup.
They did,
but you know,
for what they were doing,
they look great.
That was selling and he
was a Badass in Jujitsu.
It's a good thing to have.
Yeah.
And he's any,
does that whole cast magnet system two,
which is the,
in a sana system,
which is the Filipino system he's really
good at that was really into Weldon.
Like Kali and all that
stuff is really good.
Yeah.
He loves stick fighting,
knife fighting,
all that shit.
That shit.
Yeah.
You don't fuck with the
drummer from poison no matter
how much makeup is wearing
because they're back on tour,
he's going to be wearing all that makeup.
Just don't call them a homo telling you.
Why did you even put it
out there?
Because then someone's going to go,
Fuck Eddie Bravo.
Fuck Ricky rocket.
There's certain dudes that you meet there.
The funniest defiance conversations I
ever have with clueless folks are the
people that tell me
that if they fought MMA,
they would never lose because it's just
a mentality because of that mentality.
But how many times have
you talked to that guy,
that guy,
there's been,
there's this many,
many of those guys out there and
you drift into them like icebergs.
Like it'd be backstage at the UFC and you
don't even realize you're talking to a
crazy person until they
say something like that.
Like,
you know,
I mean these guys are
all tough and everything,
but I'll tell you my mentality.
I can't lose the fucking,
yeah.
You know what man,
that guys like me,
you don't get in there.
That's the difference guys like me
with my mentality that you know the gun
there,
they never stopped.
The referee couldn't pull me off.
Okay.
I usually get the guys that say,
you know,
they don't do that.
I'm then maybe they don't train,
but if anything went down they would
kick them in the knee and I'm like,
really?
Are you how?
How often are you practicing this kick?
How many days a week?
How long?
I mean if he was highly,
three days a week was sitting,
you know,
sit in front of the bag and
just kick into the knee,
45 minutes a day,
three days a week,
I might believe he's onto something like,
damn,
maybe he's got this crazy
because you didn't know how to
fight and you ran into some Moitai guy.
For whatever reason,
he just decided to only kick your legs
out from under you and just kick your
legs until you're done.
Like that could be possible.
Yeah,
that's possible.
That's a guy who's really good at that.
I could do that,
but the knee kick,
man,
come on,
come on son.
Yeah,
and they believe it.
They believe it and I end up with that.
I'm going to see that week,
the knees Bra,
it takes 10 pounds of pressure
statistics and it just snaps Bra.
There's certain statistics.
That's one of them.
The other one is you only
use 10% of your brain,
bro.
Bro,
you're only using,
you know,
they've only documented the people
who only use 10% of the brain
takes eight pounds of pressure.
Snap a Negro.
I can do that.
Really good.
Real good.
Does pseudo intelligence.
Stoner bullies,
it takes eight pounds of pressure.
It's been documented
on the history channel.
Eight pounds of pressure for a fucking
front snap kick right to the need.
It's over the fights over.
Okay.
I walk around with confidence.
Joe Or Joey Diaz talking about that.
All he needs is a kick in the knee.
How would he say Joe Rogan,
Joe Rogan.
Let me tell you something.
Can you fuck with me dog?
I got one side kick.
350 allegedly pounds is coming down.
Your fucking neat.
Well,
you've gone bitch going nowhere.
Come at me with that fucking karate shit.
Ninjitsu Fuck Outta here.
Side kicks to the knees.
Grab a slice.
That's how I'm rolling.
Have a seat back.
A lunch that needs to happen.
Uh,
Joe and Joey Diaz.
Cartoon with Joe Rogan doing the voice.
Why would you have me doing him?
Mine is a poor substitute
for the actual man himself.
It's just funny cause it's close cause
I've been around him sound just like him.
You say it's like you get into his
soul like you're saying the shit.
He would actually say that.
That's what's funny is you're doing him.
You're actually doing him.
I know Joey.
Probably as much as Joey now Joey,
how important is it to have
people like Daniel Life?
Man,
if you find yourself a Joey Diaz,
you remember be nice.
Not Guy.
Provide you with entertainment constantly.
Brian Callen when we
went hunting together,
dude,
I had a comedy show for five days.
That's what I had.
You know I did the prions,
lucky cow and it was
like the perfect move.
I turned like this boring ass camping
trip where it's 10 degrees out into a
constant comedy show where Kallan was
talking about how he likes to fuck guys.
Well this is what I'm doing.
I'm,
I'm holding you.
Okay.
And that's,
I'm holding you.
I'm looking at your ear and him,
he would just come up with all these
crazy things and we just feel it.
It was one of those jokes where it's
the same joke over and over again.
It's all about fucking guys
holding guys down a fucking guys.
But it starts off really funny
and ridiculous and then you like,
you wonder how long can this
fucking guy keep this up?
And then five days in you're
still laughing at the same data.
It's just him talking
about holding guys down,
fucking them.
And it's like he has no,
he has no shame and no limit.
You can just keep going,
going.
So it was literally like
a five day comedy show.
It was the most I've ever laughed
while freezing my dick off,
sleeping outdoors.
It was a perfect experience.
Plus he's just a fucking awesome guy and
counts one of those guys that doesn't
complain.
Like he'll just go do
what needs to be done.
Like we had to go hiking and shit.
He just goes hiking.
He doesn't give Joey Diaz
went on the trip with you.
What would you say,
Joe Rogan.
There's a fucking blondes
two miles away from my house.
Don't get me antelope.
You want to take me out to the
fucking bad lands of Montana?
Suck my Dick.
Okay.
Uh,
Dan never did nothing to me.
God wanted us to beat and D
and and in a fucking store
and buy a fucking beer.
Cheese balls or whatever.
He's fucking guys with your grey
poupon on your fucking deer burger.
Fuck Outta here.
Stuff.
A nice slice.
It's two points
and a regular coke.
Don't even fuck with that diet.
You don't know.
You don't want that type of cancer.
No.
Is a type of finger.
Isn't it crazy that we've
gotten fucking stupid
as a society that you get your product
can advertise that you have real sugar
and it's a good thing.
How retarded Roe,
we're putting that on billboards.
Well that's because of corn
made with real sugar corn syrup.
People are finding out how hard it is
for your body to process corn syrup.
Yeah,
but sugar is,
corn is the motherfucker man corner.
It's brought up.
Do you ever watch that
King Corn Documentary?
I think I have.
I've watched one crazy.
How much money there isn't growing corn,
man Mike and using corn and all sorts of
different food items and there's a lot
of like good uses for corn.
First of all,
it tastes good.
Carla cobb's delicious.
You know,
corn tortillas make,
you know,
makes for some Nice Tacos,
but the reality is that's
just not good for your body.
Especially like in corn syrup form.
And that shit's everywhere so
bad that they're advertising.
Look where we're using sugar after.
I wasn't sugar like wasn't
it sugar free as good before?
Well,
you know,
you're only supposed to get
sugar when it's attached to food.
You know,
the really the idea of extracting
sugar and then taking pure sugar,
like that's not ever supposed to happen.
It doesn't exist in nature,
which just so fucked up man.
We have to dabble with everything and
extract things and give you concentrated
doses.
That's where cocaine came from.
Yeah.
I mean if you eat the coca leaves,
it's apparently very healthy.
Like if the people that chew those leaves,
like those,
those,
those herders,
those high altitude hurt and high,
is it only grown in Colombia?
I don't know.
Why is it there?
Other countries growing coke,
it seems like it's only good.
Yeah,
believe,
yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
I think,
uh,
there's quite a few
places that can grow it,
but I think it's a climate thing.
But that doesn't make sense to me
because then why can't people grow in
greenhouses?
And you never hear about
cocaine busts where they've,
they,
they busted them with cocoa plants,
you know,
so I don't know.
I'm not a botanist.
I don't understand what the fuck's wrong,
but it seems like it would doesn't make
any sense that you'd have to get it all
from South America and less.
It's the only place where it grows.
That's the only thing
that makes sense to me.
And I remember there was some
controversy about the Egyptian mummies.
So one of the coolest things they found
was evidence of cocaine and a one of the
mummies when they did this,
like real thorough analysis of it.
And that could be one of two things.
It means either someone had made it all
the way to South America and brought
back cocaine.
That is one possibility or it's someone
from South America got in a boat and
came all the way to Egypt
and sold them cocaine,
or it was some kind of a false positive
because there was some other substance
that could mirror that.
When you're dealing with,
you know,
someone who's been dead
for 5,000 fucking years,
I'm sure there's a lot of
guesswork involved in the,
in the analysis of it,
but they were thinking that maybe the
Egyptian that got ahold of some eight
balls,
maybe the archaeologist
coke head and then like accidentally
spilled some coke on his shirt.
He's like,
no,
it's the Egyptian.
She's like,
yeah,
it's a ton and ton of
fucking gets the mummy.
He did it.
That would,
that's you gotta roll with it.
That's not outside the
realm of possibility.
If you were a,
it had to roll with chip tologist.
He didn't have a choice.
You get tired.
You using that brush all day.
You need a little pick me up.
You know,
you see,
look,
I'm just going to do
this coke this one time.
I'm just going to get really juiced up.
You gotta be a coke.
Coke had to be an archeologist.
I fucking combing rocks
with a tooth brush.
I'd be doing bath salts so kids
would forget what they were doing.
What the fuck was I dealing with?
The fuck was I doing?
They would forget what they were doing
and they would try to start different new
businesses while they were cleaning it up.
They'd be like,
dude,
I got this amazing idea.
And they would try to try to bring you in.
You're like my brother and mean.
Even though we just met
you like my brother,
I want you to come in
and this idea with me,
man,
let's do it.
Let's do it.
Fuck archaeology,
man.
Let's make a boat.
Let's make our own boat.
Archeologists can kit that.
They,
they use our archaeology
sometimes to get checks.
Like the sound.
I'm going to go to each if you want
to come with me and help me out.
Okay.
I bet they would if they were a lot
of fucking toothbrushes of here.
We like academic chicks,
you know,
like totally.
That's like a romantic thing.
A guy was like a published author and
Egyptologists and invites you to a dig.
I go,
oh my God,
how much pussy you think Georgiou
Georgiou was a handsome faster.
It's probably crushing it.
I would not want to speculate because I
don't know the man's personal situation,
but I would say that if he
wanted to Giorgio so close,
so smooth talking about the fucker.
Everyone makes fun of his hair.
He knows that he's done.
He doesn't know is that the pitches
are going to remember this hair.
It was funny,
man.
He got upset at me when I retweeted the
thing about ancient aliens debunked,
you know,
he was upset.
I'm like,
look,
this is how I looked at it.
You cannot be upset when
someone points out mistakes.
You can't shoot the Messenger.
And he was like,
I didn't know you supported Christians.
You know the kinds of fundamental,
it's Christian.
And I was like,
okay,
look you man,
I like you a lot.
And I liked that whole
subject of aliens a lot.
But that guy who made that video pointed
out a lot of shit that was an accurate
and that's important.
It's important to get shit accurate.
It's important to not make
speculations based on faulty evidence.
And when you got a television show,
you have a certain
amount of responsibility.
So in my opinion,
instead of being upset at that guy,
he shouldn't upset that they put
something out that was accurate.
But that doesn't discount the possibility
that we could have been visited by
ancient aliens.
That's where everybody wants to take one
camp or another and this debunker guy,
he's like convinced.
I used to believe that too.
But now I think it's
been thoroughly debunked.
Nothing's been debunked.
Yes,
there's,
there's one monkey.
Okay.
That looks way different
from all the other monkeys.
And the only thing that we resemble his
dogs in that we are completely different
looking,
but we can breed with each other.
Like Shaquille O'Neal could
mate with Miley Cyrus.
I mean,
they don't even look like they're
remotely the same species.
You know,
Shaquille O'Neal is seven foot,
whatever the fuck he is.
Miley Cyrus not a good example.
Like give me a really pale white girls.
Tiny.
Anyone,
Bjork,
Sia.
Donald.
Yeah,
it's Shaquille O'Neal could fuck Bjork.
And they could have a baby.
That's ridiculous.
The only place that
exists in nature is with,
with dogs.
You know,
like a baboon's can't fuck
Orangutang and get it pregnant.
It doesn't work that way.
But a dog or any dog can fuck any other
dog and they just make another dog.
Like you take crazy dogs like a beagle
and that'd be ego can fuck a uh,
one of those giant Russian Wolf dogs.
You ever seen those things?
The octa vox or whatever
the fuck it's called.
It's crazy thing.
It looks like an American
Werewolf in London.
I mean,
it's the most ridiculous looking dog ever.
Well,
they could fuck them.
They can make a little crazy
little hybrid baby that's a,
that only exists in people and dogs.
And we know that human beings,
genetically engineered dogs,
we know that,
you know,
by selective breeding and you know,
how are the fuck they did it.
They're not exactly sure.
But they know that all
dogs emanate from wolves.
Yeah.
Somehow or another from wolves came
chihuahuas and beagles and bulldogs,
all of them originated as well,
which is really fucking fascinating.
When you stop thinking about it because
we don't know about the origin of dogs,
the origin of dogs,
a very confusing and slippery subject.
So then when you start talking
about the origin of people,
what we fucking resemble
dogs quite a bit folks.
Okay.
And we don't look like
anything else around us and
we don't behave like anything
else around us where way fucking
smarter than everything else here.
What's going on?
What's going on and had,
yeah.
How'd
we get here?
It's confusing.
That video.
He was making it.
He was trying to make it look like he
was debunking the whole ancient aliens
theory.
Yeah.
He,
he pointed out some mistakes and,
but he was like debunking the
whole ancient alien theory.
There's been a million
documentaries on the shit.
The ancient aliens is done.
It would agent Allianz is doing it.
That's already been done,
but they're doing it.
They're the,
it looks the best.
It's highly produced.
It's all that history channel.
So when I saw it,
when I first saw ancient aliens are
already knew all that shit from,
um,
I didn't know everything.
I just,
I learned a lot from ancient aliens,
but the subjects were like the,
all the stuff from Zachariah Cichon,
Nia and Joe are both
in disaccharides such,
so,
so to see it on a major
television network was awesome.
Leather.
They get a date here or pounds off
or whatever that's on the TV show.
It's not on the,
the theory we've,
this is,
it was,
it'll be like watching a Jujitsu,
a documentary done by NBC,
right?
The guys at NBC,
they don't know Jujitsu that well,
but they want to do it
Jujitsu documentary.
They could easily get frauds
or dudes you don't know,
do you know,
uh,
they're not real experts in
Jujitsu and put them on the show.
And,
uh,
as a Jiu Jitsu expert,
you watch out and you're not going to,
you know,
this guy's a dumb ass.
They put that motherfucker in there,
right?
They're not.
And then someone comes around and says,
Jujitsu went,
Shit,
that guy's a fraud.
He's not even a real brown belt.
You know,
he's aligning,
they put them on TV,
but that would,
you're not denouncing
Jujitsu denouncing the show.
And he needed to be more clear about that.
He wasn't fucking up the theories.
Come on,
get the fuck Outta here.
You're going to tell me that,
uh,
you know,
there's so much evidence
I could go on and on.
You're going to tell me there isn't a
possibility that there's some crazy shit
going on.
You think like,
you got it all figured out.
There's a possibility that
anything could happen.
You know,
Joe,
I'm done.
If you,
if you look at the,
there's a bunch of different things
that happened to people and one of them
that's the most confusing to scientists
is the doubling of the human brain size
over a period of 2 million years.
It's a really shocking fossil event.
They don't know what the fuck did that.
And uh,
there's a lot of different theories
about higher protein consumption.
If we figured out
hunting and then went to,
once you started hunting,
our brains are growing because they
had to figure out how to outsmart the
animals and they connect
connected to the throwing arm.
The possibility that we figured out that
we can throw things in a manner that no
other animals can.
So then we started catching things with
spears and that that accelerated our
learning curve.
There's a lot of like weird,
but the bottom line is it's
a fucking crazy mystery.
And if,
if some alien race from another galaxy
who was unbelievably brilliant and many,
many,
many generations ahead of us in
the future to the point where,
you know,
they realized that,
uh,
in order to preserve intelligent life,
you have to seed it.
So you'd have to come to a
planet that already has life,
find the smartest thing there.
What do you got here?
This is crazy monkey thing that's
figured out how to use a stick to pick up
ants.
Okay,
good.
He's thinking,
okay,
let's take some of them and let's do
some shit to their DNA and let's see if
they survive.
And then they come back,
they leave for a few thousand years or
whatever and come back and see what the
fuck we have.
Well,
what do we have now?
While we have some new signals?
They've developed nuclear weapons.
What do you want to do?
Fuck that quick,
and then they come back and check us out.
It's very possible.
It's just,
it's just as possible as
us sending rovers to Mars,
we,
we have done that.
We have to realize that
if we have done that,
and we have existed in this,
in this planet for 4.6 billion years,
it took for a human being
to get to this point.
What if there's a planet
that's 20 billion years old?
You know what?
If there's a planet that's just double it,
let's go to 12 billion.
What the fuck are we going to be like?
It's 6 billion years or 4 billion years.
Yeah.
The whole crazy thing about the,
the 10th planet or Nibiru
that planet is that,
who knows if that's out
there really are not,
who knows?
But the,
the what,
the p,
the way people react to that theory is
that there's trillions and trillions and
trillions of stars and
planets every fucking where.
But if you believe there's a
fucking another planet out there,
you're fucking crazy.
Problem with the Nibiru
theory is that the,
it comes in between Mars and
Jupiter every 3,600 years.
That's the problem is that have depictions
of shit that happened 3,600 years ago.
It's not that reliable,
but you're talking,
you would have to go,
you would have to go to like 1000 BC.
I think that if a planet
came around and fill the sky,
that would probably be a
lot of stories about it.
And there's no stories about no planet.
Yeah.
Doesn't mean it didn't
happen and didn't just,
yeah,
walk people up.
Yeah.
Who knows if it happened or not.
But uh,
to re that reaction like it's so crazy,
like it's so magical that
there's another planet out there.
I would think you should be able to
track that thing moving if it was in an
elliptical orbit.
If it's that big,
they,
she will knows what we're getting.
Well,
who knows what Info are getting.
Do you know,
have you,
there's a video out right now.
You know how you hear about all these
different 2012 December 21st theories from
asteroids to earthquakes to solar flares,
all that dark stuff.
And then there's people that say,
oh no,
it's a spiritual awakening
time and all the mine count.
Or they didn't,
they didn't say anything about
any total destruction or anything.
You hear there's all these theories,
right?
So there's this one very,
that was fucking great.
It's probably all bullshit,
but it's great,
dude.
There's a video on youtube.
This is that.
If you Youtube Mayan
explains December 21st,
2012,
it's a f he looks like a mind
like an Indian dark skin,
long black hair.
He's got his mind little headset on or
as a Bandana on or something like white
clothes that kind of look like,
like,
cause that dealt in genres
that mine kind of weird.
Right?
And he gave a lecture in Santa
Monica and the video is everywhere.
And uh,
I don't even know.
I don't know how popular it is.
It might be nothing now
that I think about it.
But anyways,
the video is interesting.
He gives a lecture on what's
going to happen December 21st,
2012 and he explains the whole
Mayan Pyramids and everything.
They should make
that guy put all the money that he
gets from that lecture in a Bach.
Okay?
And if 2000 and listen
to the story as well.
December 23rd rolls around,
give you a 24 hour grace period.
Nothing happened.
Okay?
We plan to take that money.
Oh No,
this is,
this is what he says happens.
This is what he says happens.
He comes out and he says,
first of all,
is this the guy?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Men's side of the day
to all my brother's son,
he used to listen to this message.
It's a Mayan explains.
This is probably just hustling.
Why is it so interesting?
No,
the story out here,
right here and his story is bad.
This one,
the story is bad ass
get right.
That one right there,
that guy,
what is it?
Are you actually going to hear it in post?
So now in these times
there's
something that really bothers me
[inaudible] and it has to do with the
alignment.
The planetary alignment that's going to
happen on the 21st of December of this
year.
Are you in grand experimenters
in difficult by you want a cow?
There's a great experiment that is
going to be a fulfilled on that day.
[inaudible] and this experiment
and uses the particle accelerators.
[inaudible] scientists are
looking for the anti matter.
Those are scaling up.
Roy [inaudible] and so they want
to use this planetary alignment
degenerate.
A very high vibration.
There's an experimental
Cassie Gamma Proton Proton.
Proton.
Okay.
It's called the Proton Proton
[inaudible].
It's a proton is generated
with very large mat machines.
It's on both parts.
The colors can Kathy [inaudible]
and they're two particles that Jen,
um,
revolve in opposite directions.
All right,
stop.
Stop now.
Okay.
This is what it was.
I was going to really listen to him.
He's full of Shit and he has a sleeveless
shirt on because of two things I don't
like.
No,
but this is what he says.
He says what's happening on 2012.
You don't want to know why sucks.
These guys guys,
just a bullshit artist.
Okay.
I'm not saying,
I'm just saying it's a cool story.
Oh,
okay.
Let's just keep it going then.
I forget it.
Forget it.
Well he's just some crazy guy with
a fucking bullshit story toad.
But those guys are annoying to him.
But I love chocolate broken
when they come together,
when they collide they let go and
they release all of these protons.
What I mean fuck though for the impact
and these protons [inaudible] they
stimulate another round and the machine,
you work there on the theater
and they hit the earth
and when they hit the earth [inaudible]
they create a chain reaction,
say protons and Directional Madman.
They create a reaction towards
the direction of the magma.
Joke on those proton is the nine my hits,
the protons disparate Alison a theater
and it shoots out to the exterior of the
earth when the those and so when they
are released roping open couple of sick
Tony because they break
the tectonic plates,
I say cause they're [inaudible]
so they ignite the methane gas.
You've got silent era and
then gas escapes in the earth.
[inaudible]
and one moment of that friction
and he has a insane yet the um,
the methane catches on fire,
see Stereo and Munich Re is released
into the just talking about what happened
and then the large Hadron collider
experiments 2012 fire.
Yeah,
I understand what he's saying.
He's just stupid that he is the boss case.
And so that's how hundreds of hectares
of of forests are burned as like a woman
miss and to wall off about
a month ago that you would,
I'm not sure you can stop.
You could stop.
How did you ever get this far?
How did you ever get too
far and then repeat it,
bring it to us and with will
Ferrell doing in it is that welfare?
Yeah.
What he's saying is really exciting for,
for uh,
um,
between,
during the galactic alignment.
The reason he's explained this part
does the particle collider is that on,
they're going to do that on the 2000,
the 21st,
right when the sun is in the,
you know,
when it passes through the center of
the galaxy quest for eight minutes.
This is what he says for eight minutes,
that this is what,
why I'm great minutes.
We're going to be hit with like
energy from the center of the galaxy.
That where we feel enlightened,
like in a dream.
Did you know that Neil degrasse Tyson
says that that alignment happens all the
time and it's total bullshit.
I never knew that.
Yeah,
he's an astronomer.
I would go with him and what does he,
he does,
he says it's bullshit.
He says that a,
that alignment happens all the time.
And then these people that are
talking about this alignment,
they're not astronomers.
They really don't know
what they're saying.
That it's,
it doesn't happen every 26,000 years,
not according to Neil degrasse Tyson
and he's a fucking brilliant man.
He says that that every,
that 26,000 year cycle is bullshit.
Nonsense.
Yeah.
He says it happens all the time.
Well,
the procession of Equinox
is a 26,000 year cycle.
You're talking about a
completely different thing.
The procession of the equinox is the
wobble of the earth and that is a hundred
that there's 26,000 years,
that's for sure
proven.
I thought that here's
the center of the galaxy,
like a disk and our son,
it takes 26 it rotates like this around
it like that and it takes 26,000 years
to make that loop and then it goes through
the center and then it goes this way
down upward and then it
goes through the center.
That's what I read,
but I could be totally wrong.
I don't,
I don't even know what that means.
I'm not really sure I know what that,
you know what I mean?
Like the the the center of the galaxy.
The galaxy is a disk.
You were doing shit with your hands,
but you know what I'm talking about.
Hey Dude,
this is not a good place.
Confusing the shit out of me.
I'm looking over my shoulder,
I'm seeing people.
MMM.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if it doesn't work that way.
I Dunno.
That's what I read.
That's what,
uh,
or,
or saw on the Internet.
See that's the problem.
You know what I'm Neil degrasse
Tyson says nothing's going to happen.
So is it that,
that connection that's like
that Shit's there all the time.
Hmm.
So the sun passes through the center
of the galaxy all the time apparently.
Is that what he's saying?
We proudly the position that's going
to be,
and he said it's,
it's happened many times.
Hmm.
That's what he says.
These motherfuckers working on the
large Hadron collider though they are
unchecked,
crazy super geniuses.
You know.
I mean,
I'm not saying that we should,
uh,
stop the program that I am saying that
there's a far to people that aren't
concerned about the possibilities of
what all the crazy shit they're doing.
They're making,
they're,
they're absolutely making
little black holes.
Absolutely.
When you create that Higgs Boson particle
cause he's microscopic black holes
that are made that they don't
have enough gravity to stay,
uh,
stay active.
So they disappear really quickly.
But what the fuck?
Like what,
what kind of a crazy ass hole uses a
machine with the possibility of making a
black hole because what's going to
happen next and they're going to be happy
with these results and just stop there.
What if there's like more spectacular
energy that can be created but there's a
smaller chance the black
holes sticks around a while?
Well they're going to go,
of course they're going to go for that.
They're going to keep doing it.
They're gonna keep doing it because people
are fucking infatuated with figuring
out how shit works and they're going to
things like the large Hadron collider.
It just,
it's just one step and a never ending
process until they get to technology that
could end the universe
instantly all at once.
That's like,
it's almost inevitable if you
think about what they're doing now.
Large Hadron collider is a courageous.
The idea,
they are finding the,
they're recreating the conditions.
Millie millions of a second after the the,
the universe was created.
That's what they're doing by
smashing those atoms together.
They're recreating this particle way.
They figured that out to build.
Is it like 17 miles?
Like and,
and I'm the circle like that.
I think it's 22 I think it's 22 miles.
It might be 22 kilometers,
whatever the fuck it is.
And they saw and they smashed
these Adam's together.
But it's,
it's,
it's crazy.
They think not only
did they figure it out,
they've explained it,
got funding and then they're
out there and doing it.
That is some,
that is alien,
right?
They're not us.
Those who,
I don't know any other
people that can do that.
And how the fuck did they do that?
Those are aliens.
I mean it's,
it's like it's a circle,
like a tube in a circle
and they run particles like
simultaneously and then they
run into each other.
So I don't understand it.
I'm not swollen.
Then when they collide,
the explosion that they're taking
snapshots of the explosion to see what the
hell is going on.
They're trying to find the God particle.
They believe they've isolated that.
And there's also something called cork
glue on plasma that that's another thing
that they've created.
They've created a new kind of
matter that didn't exist before,
that did to do a lot of freaky shit.
This cork gluon plasma.
I think if you made,
I think the dimensions are a sugar
cube would weigh 40 million pounds.
It might be billion.
Let me see.
Cork.
I gotta I gotta pull that
up cause it's fucking crazy.
When I read the quote glue on Plasma,
wait,
when I read the quote I was like,
what the fuck are they doing?
They're making some shit that
it's just like infinitely heavy.
And uh,
this is something that it was a,
I believe this was all
basically they were,
this is all theoretical
until really recently.
I know that the um,
they,
oh my God,
okay.
They,
the court glow on plasma has
an approximate temperature
of 4 trillion degrees
Celsius.
Okay.
Holy Shit.
4 trillion degrees.
This is weird shit to like,
to reality and to matter that they're
starting to figure out like things like
this.
Like this court glue on plasma and uh,
the Higgs Boson and,
and whatever this new matter
thing that they figured out,
they figured out some new kind
of matter that they've created.
Like all of this is like very,
very,
very strange.
Isn't it crazy getting most of our info
from Twitter feeds out to hunting the
latest,
coolest info down and,
and they just tweeted the boom.
You see it on Twitter or family matters.
Yeah.
That's good.
Sure.
What are you talking about?
You were talking about
matters weren't too,
oh
how dare you.
How dare you Brian.
You need to go to a doctor.
I told you this many times.
What were we talking about before that?
Before he came into march to hell.
Join Collider.
Why do you think that's funny?
That's funny.
Just like that.
I know it's impossible.
What?
Move away from that one.
Don't worry about it.
The um,
the,
the network that we have
though with Twitter,
all the people sending you shit,
it's really an incredible thing
that never existed before.
The idea that people all around
the world find cool shit.
They sent it to you cause they know
you're retweet it if you find cool shit.
And they just keep doing that.
So you're constantly every
day getting new clothes.
Shit,
the latest cool shit.
You know what's annoying though man?
The occasional parody site.
Fuck you fake news.
Fuck you.
You're fucking boring ass fake news.
That shit's boring.
I don't like any of it.
I think the onion does it really
well and the onion does it.
They do.
And by the way,
it's the onion.
You go to the onion,
you know what the fuck the onion is?
Yeah.
There's all these fake onions that are
coming along and they'll make these fake
stories and occasionally a rope you in.
And someone was like,
dude,
it's a parody site.
Like it's on pace.
I love what the fuck kind of
parody is that where you just lied?
What are that the,
when you lie it's just a lie.
It's just a fake fuck it.
It's not,
it's not even remotely
weird enough to be fake.
You should check out the young Turks
have you have,
and we had the cohost
on today on the podcast.
And then I think you'd
really like her lunch.
Yeah,
she's great.
Yeah.
What?
We talked about it yesterday.
Um,
I talked about it with um,
machine Smith the other day too.
Yeah.
What happened with her?
I did.
Did you know that that's the
number one news right now.
Her channel,
her channel is the number one online news.
That makes sense.
Isn't that crazy?
Makes Sense.
People don't want to
watch CNN online anymore.
They did another getting
bullshitted and then by the way,
they also know they're going to have to
sit through these fucking commercials
every time it jumps to a new story.
You ever go to cnn.com?
Yeah.
Great source of information.
But it makes you want to put your fucking
head through a wall when you start
listening to their videos
because if you watch their video,
every fucking video,
you have to watch a 32nd commercial.
So it's over and over and over again.
And usually it's the
same God damn commercial.
So over and over and over again,
you're listening to this stupid nonsense
about detergent or whatever the fuck it
is.
And you get to the point where like,
this is crazy.
Play me 10 in a row.
Okay,
play me three in a row.
You can't have a fucking commercial
after each God damn video.
So that's how the young Turks,
they just sneak in steel CNNs thunder.
She says he'll come on the
podcast if we ever liner.
Okay.
That'd be just fine.
She was fine.
I think you'd like her.
She's very intelligent.
It's cool.
Pretty cool.
Smartsheet.
Yeah.
I wonder how much the CIA
has been following her.
If you tell him some real
news on the Internet,
who act like one of those people?
No,
this is a different one.
Eddie,
have you ever been to a
dance club where they uh,
like somebody has like this little
glowy pins that attached to their,
uh,
their fingers?
Have you seen those?
They're like,
they're like glow sticks
that attached to your,
your fingers.
I don't know.
I haven't been to a club in a long time.
It's so funny.
I saw a guy the other day in San Diego
and he had these like little things that
you attached to your fingers that,
that are like glow sticks,
but you go like this and
they flash around like,
I guess it's like are a rave
thing now that a popular,
but it was hilarious watching him dance
with that shit too lazy for glow sticks.
Like,
you know what man?
I'm like,
I like glow sticks but I
don't want to carry things.
Can you make them stick to my fingers so
I could just move my fingers right now?
It's so weird.
It's,
it's the gay,
the gay is with an age thing.
You will ever see somebody dance
around with those things on his finger.
Look,
I've seen Saturday,
dude,
I've seen a lot of sad shit.
At least glowsticks kind of look
cool in your high something to them.
It's funny how one sort of a
thing got attached to one drug,
you know,
ecstasy and glow sticks.
You know,
it's kind of interesting.
Well,
when young ecstasy
lights are way brighter.
So yeah.
Well,
and also it's like hypnotic.
When you see it like trailing in the air,
you know,
there's like a certain trail
quality to those glow sticks.
Here's a,
here's a guy who got,
if you're looking at the video or
you don't have video over there,
that sucks,
just play it in the,
uh,
the,
the thing,
what am I looking at here?
That he has him on these like little
things and so you see these guys dancing
around.
Oh
my God,
it's the most ridiculous thing ever.
I don't know if they're saying south.
Yeah,
but like this was like,
I saw all these people
in San Diego have them.
They got me and Doug Benson were at a
dance club and saw it like a guy doing
this shit.
And it's just like,
is that the new thing?
I feel like an old man.
I would say it's definitely
not the new thing.
I do not see that.
Catch you.
It was funny watching people dance it.
I didn't even know it existed.
Man.
What'd you ever do that again?
Uh,
yeah,
sure.
It's a movement.
Even in Austin.
If the rhythm gets me,
I might go and put on some
fucking low stick thing,
ease and dance like a motherfucker.
Have you guys heard about this lawsuit
whether is a pill that this dude took
that turned him into a
gay sex and gambling act?
The court has upheld this ruling.
Okay.
The a ruling against the
pharmaceutical giant Glasko Smith.
They had to pay 197,000 euros to a man
who claimed that the drug used to treat
his Parkinson's,
turned him into a gay
sex and gambling addict.
What?
Yeah.
What's the translation and money?
Was that 10 bucks that they had to pay?
Oh,
I didn't do it.
$51,000
they paid him $151,000
how's that possible?
I don't know,
man.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
So the guy said the drug made him addicted
to internet gambling and caused him
to lose the family savings and steal
to feed the habit that cost him 82,000
euros.
Then he said he attempted suicide eight
ten eight times and became a compulsive
gay sex addict exposing himself on the
Internet and cross dressing is risky.
Sexual encounters led to him being raped.
All that stopped when
he ceased taking Requip.
This is the stuff called Rep quip,
right?
Quip Rec clip has been known for
years to have undesired side effects,
but a warning only appeared on its
package insert in 2006 the Lord said,
who is,
so this was in 2003 this guy was taking
this stuff before the company admitted
that there's some horrific side
effects with certain peeves,
engage juice in there.
So well,
it's funny man.
People are a series of,
you know like the way your,
your whole system works as he,
there's a series of chemicals that
interact with the body and everybody has a
different set up and we all
know people who can't drink.
We all know people you ever met
anybody who can't eat peanuts.
This they,
those mother fuckers get
nervous around peanuts.
Like they can't eat peanuts.
Third,
their throat would close up.
There's some people that like normal shit,
they're allergic to something.
A lot of people are alerted to wheat.
It turns out there's a lot of
gluten out so the body's weird,
but I've never heard of something
turning into a gay sex addict who was the
lawyer or the pharmaceutical company and
like Earl shy or something like that.
Maybe this guy is just a really good liar.
Doesn't like to see his testimony please.
If they paid,
doesn't that kind of mean that?
Yeah,
it actually works.
What means they were able to prove
to the jury and what does that mean?
I mean the jury's generally
try to side with people.
I think when they would check,
can't pharmaceutical companies
so the guy could just have it.
He could've got caught on this,
just mad fucking gay sex and gambling
binge and his wife found out and she's
like,
if you don't seek help,
but they over and they cited
something on in 2006 they out.
They admitted the side effects,
but that actually,
I have to admit,
don't they?
The actual side effects that happened.
Well,
I would assume it's not gay sex addict
because that shit would have been out by
now.
I would imagine that there's a lot
of people that take this Parkinson's
medication.
If they all became crazy gay sex addict,
I just want to try it.
That would be like a gay sex Voodoo drug.
Could you imagine if you took some
shit and it made you a gay sex addict?
Like if it was,
if this human sexuality was that
manipulate manipulatable manipulable,
if it was at that age you to manipulate
where someone can actually add something
to your system and we'll
turn you into a sex addict,
man,
that'd be so many gay dudes doing that.
Two straight guys.
What's funny is the CIA
tried to do that in Iraq.
They were trying to create a gay bomb.
This is a true story.
They were,
they were trying to find out if it was
possible to make something that could
blow up over the city.
It would rain down on these people and
they would all fall in love with men and
it would kill their morale and they
wouldn't want to fight anymore.
And they would be ashamed
and they would like,
they would lose their ambition to fight.
That's amazing.
Well,
it's really ridiculous too,
because the,
the greatest warriors in the history
of humanity have been gay guys.
There's been a lot of
gay sex and the Romans,
a lot of gay sex and the Greeks,
I mean,
before North America ever even
was populated with houses,
these guys were fucking people up with
swords and banging each other in the ass.
So they were the kings back then.
So the idea that you could drop a bomb
on these Iraqis and then all of a sudden,
other's butts acts would
just be going off and no one,
no one would feel like they
would need to fight back.
But if you turn them into
like some crazy super warrior,
Greek homo gods,
and they just all started fucking
Americans up because they loved each other
because they're all gay sex in each
other all day and they don't want,
they fight even harder because they
don't want to lose their boyfriends.
Yeah.
They love going on the road.
You know what I mean?
Like for,
they're like camels.
You don't need it.
They don't need any pussy.
That's a good way looking at it,
man.
They could just wander through the woods.
Imagine that Shit.
If they really could.
The CIA really was trying to do that.
The
CIA gay bomb.
If you just Google that,
you'll find that study.
It's a,
it's hilarious.
Probably be best.
Like if you were running shit and Spain
back in the conquistador days to get a
crew of nothing to gay dates,
right.
Because then you won't have
to worry about them being,
I'll starve at the Saxon love,
I guess.
You know,
the,
um,
the other thing they would do is,
uh,
they would apparently the CIA
would make a fake Islamic gay porn.
They would like.
Yeah,
they would organize the gay porn and
make it like dudes it speaking Arabic.
So they fill,
listen,
he goes to talks from Erin Burg than
you know soccer's deck and he's going to
put in your ass and they would
organize the show themselves.
They would organize the
gay porn shoots themselves.
So then they would say,
oh,
look at all this Islamic gay porn.
So the CIA was making gay porn in
order to make the other side look bad.
I wonder if there were executive
producing it or if they were like,
actually
we're going to have to do this ourselves.
We can't trust actors.
But what if they tell our story
and the government could lose its
battle with the Islamic terrorists.
So listen,
you're going to have to suck my dick.
I'm going to have to fuck
you and ridiculous to him.
Good ideas.
Now I was in the CIA.
I'd be,
I'll be out for,
I'd be pushing for that one.
I'll be voting for that one.
This would be funny.
Would you want to be in the CIA and
Ma and be in the gay porn division?
What'd you think that would be?
How would you want to one the worst jobs?
I'd want to be in the brainwash division.
Like all the different
ways to brainwash people.
I'd be fascinated with that.
They really did think that they were
going to be able to do that in the 1990s.
They were uh,
they spent a lot of money on this man.
The theory was that the bomb would release
a chemical compound that would render
the opposing troops so irresistibly horny
that instead of raising their rifles
to defend their nations,
they would turn ravenously gay and raise
something else in [inaudible] and have
passionate sex with each other.
Did it sounds like they figured it out.
Wow.
And as an added bonus,
the burst of gay sex would leave.
Yeah.
The enemy troops in
masculinity with shame.
How many dudes like play tricks and
pranks on their friends to slip some gay
drugs and drink?
That would be like so common.
You're a teacher and then have gay sex
with your teacher would if they really
liked it.
What if the,
like when they got on the
gauge rog and it was like,
wait,
like look,
I thought it was straight until today,
but like the gay life is for me,
I just need,
it's way more fun.
I just need to take these gay drug
like once every couple of days.
Give me a dose of hyper.
I feel loved.
Like they go to clubs and all of a
sudden they can get laid and they feel
understood.
Like the Sim man,
a man understands a man.
Women pretend to understand men just to
keep you around and sort of stare at you
and shake their head at
you every now and then.
Cause it disappointed.
But it dude understands it.
Dude.
The smells of a guy
being gay must be awful.
Being a gay person
in the daily smells you have to deal with.
Well they don't all bumped.
Fuck.
A lot of them just blow each other.
So the smells would be pretty similar
to what you're smelling already.
Yeah.
But when you're spinning up to your
man at night and you just smell it,
but you know it's going
to be worse than a check.
I don't know man.
Probably like really clean
what it feel like a Vegan.
I was talking about bears guys know,
sorry.
Oh I know you get the clean one.
This is that what you think you would get?
You'd get like a time sucker or Bert
Kreischer but would you guys be like dual
bears or would you,
uh,
would you like battle like those bears
do when those open fields they start
pulling their hair out or would
you just let them be the top bear?
I don't know.
It's a good question cause bear seem
to always get along for a little while
until there's some pussy around and then
you see bears going off on each other
and brawl and in the fields.
So is pussy that brings them to that.
So,
uh,
I wonder if there was no pussy involved,
it was just a two dudes.
Would that even,
would that even be an issue?
I don't know.
Maybe gay bears would be cool to
like camp near hybrid net with them.
Hibernate hybrid nut.
I mean it happened that all over this man.
If you wanted to have a gay relationship,
would you want a gay relationship
with a bear type gay dude?
A super obvious,
like like a really super femme gay dude
or a dude who looks exactly like a girl
but has it Dick.
Ooh,
because you know,
yep.
I don't want to take that
gay drug to give you now.
What'd you take the
gates rather quick show.
Soon as it kicks in you're like,
oh dude,
I filling him young Asian boys.
Yeah.
Do that for the podcast.
We just contain ourselves
inside the room so that we
strapped ourselves up to
make sure extra tight.
Make sure it's tight.
Yeah,
really,
really buckle down and take
a spoonful of that shit.
I wouldn't trust Dropbox.
I was just duct tape my
dick and my buddle just,
yeah,
just in case I wouldn't trust you guys.
I wouldn't trust you at Oh man,
it kicks.
You would like to let me out.
Come on.
You can do it.
[inaudible].
He spits out a key out of his mouth.
I said,
where's
catch you with your toes?
Unlike duct tape,
I put,
I tried.
That's hilarious.
Houdini style that don't be ridiculous.
You'd have to see the Dude Mama.
It's like that scene
in a,
the wolf man when he said that,
all the scientists are surrounding
him trying to diagnose it.
I don't know if you ever
southern Benicio del Toro,
Wolf Man,
stupid ass movie,
but it costs a couple of cool
werewolf scenes and then the straps,
they thought the straps are
going to hold them down.
No,
no fucking burst right through that shit.
Just like that gay last would do for you.
Yeah,
with it.
Giant raging hard on just
purple and the angry.
Just demand satisfied
faction like that.
Dolphin calm down,
calm down.
Imagine
you already feel like shit.
What if feeling like,
oh my God,
I just sucked this dude's Dick.
You start being by for a little bit.
Maybe that's what it is.
It's like,
no,
I'm not drunk,
but I'm buzzed.
Be a buy for a little.
I wonder if they're ever gonna figure
out a way or if humans keep evolving,
if we're ever going to separate
the idea of sex and making people.
Because if you look at,
like if you look at all the images that
people claim to have seen like of these
aliens,
the gray aliens,
they all are set clothes.
They have no organs
that have no sex organs.
And you got to wonder man,
if,
if we,
we keep fucking around with genetics and
we keep fucking around with artificial
scan and all this weird shit that's going
on right now that they're there in the
middle of a experimenting
with artificial cells,
artificial.
Adam's like all really strange.
I don't know if they could do artificial
atoms but really strange shit.
And the idea is that one day,
what if they just say,
listen,
when we have sex,
we have these problems and
there's a lot of emotions.
We've figured out a way
to isolate those sayings,
feelings and you can get that with a pill.
And then we could just recreate
people with like skin cells.
We can make you a person and you could
raise that person and the person just
take a,
take a skin cell from you and run
it through a fucking computer.
What do you want?
You want a boy?
You want a girl?
It doesn't matter.
Everybody looks the same that he's got a
deck and they'd come out and if we keep
going,
if the technology and the,
the,
the symbiotic relationship
that human beings have to it.
If that shit keeps going,
which it obviously it's going to,
we're going to start fucking
with the human body and we're,
we're certainly more likely to move
away from monkey instincts and,
and the,
the,
the certain needs that caused
people to want to dominate others,
to want to fuck others,
to want to plant seeds.
Like,
well,
if we really look at it all objectively,
we might one day decide to
slowly move away from that.
And it might take a few thousand years,
but if it might get to a point where
as a culture they recognize that these
lustful feelings that we enjoy today and
that motivate people to build buildings
and drive fast cars and
fucking learn how to fly a jet.
Those that might be,
that might be a thing of the past.
They might figure out a way to engineer
human beings to the point where sex is
no longer part of the equation.
That's a real mind fuck man.
If they come up with something
that feels better than sex though,
it's totally possible.
They come up with some sort
of an artificial reality,
some simulated thing,
some fucking
or sex that you can eat
sex that you could eat,
like imagine something
ambitious and it's it.
It fulfills your sexual flow.
The more you fuck,
the better it gets.
I want to,
how many people out there?
I had zero sex drive,
like they just had a condition.
Zero sex drive.
They do not want to fuck ever.
I'm sure there's quite a few.
Who are those guys?
I wonder if if it's,
you know,
there's super happy people like that.
Yeah.
Can you be super happy?
Sure.
For sure.
Have like hobbies,
you know,
motivate you.
There's a lot of people are
just not motivated by sex.
You know,
I met a lot of people that are in
relationships that don't have sex anymore.
That's when it gets really
weird and they tell you,
hey,
we're like more friends than anything.
I mean,
I don't even care anymore.
Like what I know.
And Dude,
his wife had a baby,
he had a hard time having
getting some sex as it was.
Like,
it was always the joke around the set.
We worked together.
It was always a joke around the set.
Oh,
he's talking about he can't get laid.
Everybody would talk about this
poor guy who couldn't get laid.
And then finally his wife had a kid.
So I guess he got laid and she got
pregnant and then she shut it off no more.
And His kid is now three and he has had
no sex with her since you got pregnant.
And that's just madness.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
how can I go live like that?
Like how,
how could a guy like,
she just,
she just no desire to
please him and he's like,
I go,
do you try?
It's like,
Oh yeah,
she shuts me down every time.
Like you keep trying.
Wow.
For some girls probably think that,
you know,
I'm pregnant.
It's,
it's disrespectful to the
baby or some kind of shit.
Like,
no,
forget about that.
The kids three.
Oh,
the kids three.
There's been no sex since the baby.
Like she got,
she got a baby and she's like,
I don't like that shit.
We're done.
I don't need it.
I don't need you.
That's crazy.
That's a,
that's a bad situation for a guy to be in.
Man.
That's a,
that's a,
that guy is like a heroin addict that
lives with a big fat Stasha heroines
sitting on the kitchen table,
you know,
it's all the,
the,
all his needs could be sexually
fulfilled by this other person.
But this other person's like,
nope,
I don't like it.
I don't want to do it.
Well,
she does that then obviously
that's good to hurt her.
He said allowed to cheat.
I would.
I would say,
well,
he should get out of the relationship.
That's a bad relationship.
We're just don't bring it up around it.
And you've got a kid involved.
Yeah,
she'd probably be happy if he cheated.
Get out of here,
bitch.
Trying to fuck me.
I haven't had sex in three years.
Three years for 100% I wouldn't bullshit.
He wouldn't bullshit.
He's a good dude.
He's a real good dude.
Shit that went on the last three months.
Yeah.
How long do you think you would last with,
with a woman if she would refuse to have,
sorry,
three months,
but three months is a long time.
What kind of reason she had?
What was the reason you dig stank?
No,
that's true.
It would depend on the reason.
Like if you had did something wrong
and if everything's fine and
there's no sex for couple of weeks,
I
would think something was wrong.
Like wait,
there's two weeks,
this is ridiculous.
Two weeks.
One week was ridiculous,
but you know,
two weeks.
It's just something's wrong.
Well,
they just don't need it as much.
Some of them.
Some of them needed more.
That's when shit gets annoying.
Some of them are addicted to it.
The worst is when your check once
a fuck one you do and you're like,
Jesus Christ,
I got shit to do.
Yeah,
you want another one?
Ah,
God damn it.
Can I just go to sleep?
Yeah.
Those are in the early days.
Well,
I think a lot of,
uh,
young people do that too,
to sort of distract them from the,
the,
the realities of life.
Life is just so fucking
confusing when you're younger.
You just want to escape and just
fuck all the time and fall in love.
I think they're just really,
really hydrated and the need
to get that shit out of them.
I don't like it that
I can't see your face.
You were going to move this screen.
No more of this.
You're hiding behind their throwing shit.
Balls,
bunker.
It's fun,
but it's also quite a conversation killer.
You're fuck
occasionally they worked though.
Occasionally.
They're really good.
My ex was a squirter and
that's what I was saying.
Yeah,
that shits nasty.
I like it.
A lot of girls like Dana Deanna
and she says that's just pissed.
She's the line.
But she's a girl,
man.
I can you say she knows what's up.
Squirt in the girl's pissing
all over you son snap pics.
It has a piss smell type smell to it.
But I don't think as long as
it has a piss type smelling,
that probably precludes the
possibility of it being pissed.
I mean,
why would it be pissed if
it had a piss like smell?
Maybe we need to get
the point drew in here.
Yeah,
Dr Drew,
it has no information that's
accurate about marijuana.
What the fuck do you think
he would tell you that?
What?
Do you still have your going off
all of the information to his show?
I would definitely do it.
Should.
You would think that he
probably wouldn't want no,
she,
listen,
I've never said anything.
Yeah,
well that's not true.
Um,
he's done some silly things when it came
to marijuana and the silliest thing is
nonsense.
And he says on a CNN show
about these horrible,
a addictive withdrawals that people have
and the withdrawal symptoms that people
have for marijuana.
That's crazy.
And he knows it.
That is fucking crazy.
The people who have any
physical withdrawal from
marijuana are extremely rare
shrimi way.
But you know,
I could get,
get,
get we've away from Joey Diaz that
he would probably go through physical
withdrawals.
I don't think so.
No.
He takes days off a week,
man.
It's not a physical thing.
Joey likes to be high for sure.
Yeah,
definitely add medicating
or whatever the fuck he has,
but yeah,
but we're talking about the dude.
He could not,
he would get annoyed with you.
Okay.
He would want to be high again,
but physically his body
would not be addicted to it.
So that's where withdrawal syndrome,
you're probably sweating at night.
I think.
I just see him maybe
wrong,
man.
I mean,
look,
there's some people that
get addicted to toothpaste.
Okay.
There's people that get
addicted to everything.
There's a lot of weirdness
in the world of addictions.
But to say that it's one
of the more dangerous
drugs and then there's like
dangerous withdrawal syndromes.
That's nonsense and knows
it's not the gateway theory,
there's no connection,
there's no connection in
marijuana physically to addiction.
It's not like opiates where there's an
established connection of addiction.
The,
there's no chemical established like
connection of addiction to marijuana.
It's not something that like Rob's your
brain of dopamine and then you need it
to like read,
get your high again.
It doesn't work that way.
Yeah.
So for someone that discounts it
and then the other problem is they,
they,
they belittle it.
They say,
well look,
Hey I'm,
I'm all for it.
You want out?
Smoke your pot.
Go ahead and smoke your pot.
That's what you want to do.
Some people like to drink,
some people like to smoke pot.
And the problem with that is that they're
talking from a non experienced point
of view.
They're not a person who has had any
psychedelic experiences and they're not a
person who has had any cannabis
experiences that were enlightening.
And you and I both have had some crazy
experiences eating and smoking at
whatever where we broke down some certain
aspect of our life and change things
and looked at things in a
different way and created things.
And music has come from it
and ideas have come from it.
And then an understanding
of yourself comes from it.
And to discount that is ignorance.
Especially if you haven't
experienced it and you,
you are dealing with a
broken group of people.
You're dealing primarily with people
that come to someone when shit is fallen
apart.
But guess what?
There's a lot of people
that aren't falling apart.
It's not the same drug as all these
drugs that people are taking when a
scratching their face off
and you can't call it a drug.
You cannot call it a drug because there's,
there's no meth advocates,
there's no people,
uh,
you know,
trying to tell you that you just get a
little crystal and you're going to get
your life in order.
You know,
get a little crystal and change
your perspective cause man,
why don't you just look at
things in a fresh manner,
broach,
get a little crystal in your system
and then listen to this song.
Math magazines
when they show have posters of like
the pinups of the crystal up close.
So you shit,
oh this is,
this is ice.
Oh Shit.
This is the shit from breaking bad.
This is the shit that the
chemicals make the um,
the photos and the high times and
all those things are so hilarious.
They have like pinups of weed.
Yeah,
I never got that.
That's ridiculous.
I love weed,
you know that.
But I've never been into wheat so much
where I'm going to put up a pinup of
like,
you know,
purple haze or some shit.
It really is beautiful.
I can't wait until it becomes legal
because when it becomes legal,
I'm going to start eating it.
And I don't even mean to get you high.
I mean eating it raw,
which by the way,
it can't get you high.
But apparently it's super nutritious
like marijuana and the seeds and like
eating it raw.
Apparently bud,
like the mud,
the leaves,
all that Shit.
Yeah.
You just pluck it off the stem.
You don't eat the stems,
but all those leaves and shit
apparently it's like really nutritious.
Apparently eating marijuana,
it's like super good
for you and it doesn't
get you high at all.
You could juice it really
good for you if you juice it.
It's just so many different personalities.
It's almost,
it's almost seems like a joke when you
start talking about all the different
things that it can do.
It's like,
come on.
If it could do all those things,
let's be realistic.
It would be legal.
Come on.
That doesn't even make any sense,
but you find out you can eat it.
You can make houses out of it,
like why?
It's what,
what else?
What gets you high and you
can make houses out of it.
You know,
Henry Ford made the first
fucking car out of it,
the first fucking car,
the fenders of the car,
the body of the car was made out of hemp.
That's how much they respected.
The drug thing is ridiculous too,
because 95% of all the stoners,
I know they don't do heroin or Meth,
they just smoke weed.
If it was a gateway drug,
that'd be a big problem with all
my friends with math and heroin,
there's not a problem.
The whole gateway thing is all bullshit.
They're going to,
they're going to find the a way
to stop people from smoking weed.
And what they're going to do is they're
going to mix up that shit from that
Parkinson's medication.
They're going to get into the weeds supply
and everybody's going to go gay bomb
with the week.
You know,
with Colorado,
you know,
you hear,
we've talked about this about a week ago,
that they had one of the worst
economies in the state and now with,
with we that one of
the best in the states.
I mean,
that's what I was told.
I don't know if it's true,
but yeah,
that's the metal that
doesn't seem like they would,
how,
okay,
let's,
let's look,
um,
economic impact in Colorado,
unless I was told total bullshit.
And it could be,
yeah,
that sounds like one of those,
dude,
they were ready to totally close the
state and quit being a state and then we'd
came along and now
they're rich San hazing.
No,
it wasn't like quite like,
okay,
no,
I have weed in Colorado.
Yeah.
If that's true,
isn't that I should write Merrill's and
that's something that would influence
other states if it did that,
if it completely turned
their economy around,
the real issue is the problem
that dummies get to vote.
That's the real problem.
The real problem is dummies get the vote
and a lot of dummies have these like
fundamentalist ideas
about it and they just,
they just can't accept the
fact that first of all,
you should be able to do
whatever the fuck you want to do.
I'm a grown man.
You're a grown man.
Just cause you believe in,
you know,
whatever.
It doesn't mean you can stop me from
doing what I want to do if it doesn't hurt
anybody else.
So that,
that right away as a problem because
not everybody agrees with that.
There's a,
there's a lot of fucking dummies.
It's dummy's get the vote.
But how many,
how many states have
medical marijuana now?
I believe it's a 16 or
something like that.
And now they just made,
um,
Massachusetts just got through.
Can you find that out Brian?
How many states are medical marijuana?
Cause it was 13,
like it seemed like eight years ago.
And like now,
Brian,
you didn't want to do that?
No,
the Internet's not working on that,
this laptop very well,
so I'm sure really fuck anything up.
Okay.
I'm using my phone just to
look at Twitter and there.
All right,
well let's assume it's a lot.
Let's say I think it's like 16,
but the,
um,
I think that
eventually the,
the,
the Washington state's and the,
the Colorados two places 18.
Wow.
The,
the two states that made it legal,
the,
what's going to be really interesting
to see is what happens from here.
Because if the federal government
still decides to fuck with them,
they can.
And that's where it gets really strange.
So if these people start up legitimate,
we'd stores that are legitimate
under their state law,
just like liquor stores pay their pay,
their taxes and all that shit.
Does the government come down on them
because they can't if they want and they
have before.
There's a case of a guy
from Montana and it's a,
he's becoming a big martyr once people
found out about it on the Internet,
cause this guy regularly had law
enforcement from state law enforcement.
He invited them on tours of his grow up.
He did everything legit.
Everything by the book checked
double checked with everybody,
follow the state law to a t.
But the government came in and
arrested him under federal laws.
They wouldn't even let him use the term
medical marijuana because it doesn't
exist federally.
So this guy's looking at
80 years in prison and this
guy did everything correct.
That's where it gets Montana.
That's where it gets
really fucking squirrely.
Because look,
when there's a guy who's not hurting
anybody and he's giving someone something
that should be legal in your area
because the people voted on it.
If you want to lock that guy up,
your,
the criminal and that,
that,
that's uh,
that's an important point to make in
this society that just because someone
wrote some shit down on paper and you
can interpret it in a way that you decide
you could put someone in jail and if
you put someone in jail that's not doing
anyone any danger and he puts him in jail
for 80 fucking years for selling happy
plants,
you're a criminal.
Like you're uh,
cultural criminal.
I've got someone who's a robing society.
That's someone who we have to pay.
We pay them tax dollars and they arrest
people who aren't hurting anyone.
You're telling me there was another
shit you guys could have done.
You're telling me those
cops that arrested that guy,
they couldn't have been like busting
burglaries or burglar or leaves or uh,
are arresting murderers or you know,
fucking kicking down the
door of a crack house.
Why the fuck are they going after
this guy who keeps having cops and law
enforcement and mayors over his property
to show them his grow up because
everything's done under state law and
paying his taxes because there's a bunch
of criminals in government,
man,
the actual government itself,
it's filled with criminals and they think
that they're allowed to do it because
it's written down somewhere.
It's a federal law.
The federal law against
marijuana has been the same since
federal government to change its position.
The federal government
doesn't change his position.
That's whole Harris.
That is,
hi Larry [inaudible] that.
That is one thing.
I mean there's anything that makes
the government out to be horse.
It's their stance on marijuana.
It's one of the,
one of the biggest
whore like stances because scientists
should have long ago convinced politicians
that there's massive benefit to
this country if we grow this stuff,
if we grow it,
if we sell it,
look,
it's cultural benefit.
There's artistic benefit and then
there's farmers benefiting financially,
not just by selling the drug,
but by selling the hamp and all this shit.
But that's not the kind of fucking
law enforcement we have here.
Eddie Bravo.
Yeah.
They don't think right.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
you're good for about an hour and a half,
two and then you always do this.
He just locked down here a burst of
stories and then he just like set it up.
That's the first wave of the week.
No,
no,
no.
I'm good.
I'm kidding,
man.
The first wave.
I agree with you.
It's an incredible,
I mean
it's,
it's incredible what the
information that's coming out with,
you know,
for the last 10 years
we've been talking about,
you know,
all this fishy ass shit that the
government does like with nine 11,
all this fishy ash.
Did you see the news report where they
finally released a video from hotel
surveillance?
It was on the news.
It's on youtube where they show before
they only showed three frames of the
explosion at the Pentagon.
Now they show the whole thing.
There's an explosion.
There's no plane.
What is this?
There's a video on youtube.
It's just,
uh,
w what is it called?
Hmm.
Maybe Pentagon explosion.
Yeah.
Just put Pentagon explosion video.
All right.
You in this is legit.
I mean it appears to be legit.
You know what,
even even if it isn't legit,
if it's like a hoax,
it is.
It's still,
it's like a,
you know,
the government is like
the neighborhood whore,
you know,
it's,
if,
if she gets accused of
boning your friend Tommy,
you're like,
you know,
it's probably happened.
Even if it didn't happen,
she's still at whore.
Okay.
The actual hidden footage,
no airplane.
This was October of 2012 so
that must be the new shit,
right?
Only 992 views.
I would think it was around
for like more than a month.
More than a thousand people.
Right.
So maybe there's a bunch
of videos like that.
Maybe they made copies.
Okay.
Let's see what happens here.
Hmm.
Wow,
that's hard to tell.
Um,
it looks like,
first of all,
it's way in the distance and
it's really blurry as fuck.
I guess this is like a security camera,
but it actually does look
like someone flies in there.
It actually does,
dude,
that like that looks like
a fucking complaining.
The last,
yeah,
the last one.
It could be,
you know what people are saying?
It's either a bomb or a missile.
Yeah,
there's,
there's actually something
like really clear watch.
Watch this.
Look at this slide here.
There's something really
clear that in right now.
Watch.
See that.
See that white thing.
And then boom.
So that,
that's like a plane.
There's something right here
under this that comes at it.
And then it hits set.
Watch one more time.
Right here.
It's right there.
See that?
Boom.
It's like she could see something
fly into it cause people are crazy.
Um,
listen to the news.
It would actually listen to the
audio and listen what they say.
They say there's no point.
I look and guess what?
There's no plane.
Yeah,
maybe they're retarded.
Those people that are
reading the news man thing,
so smart,
those fuckers,
all they do is they just
read off a prompter.
I've never been impressed
with the knowledge of the
people that read the news.
Then they can all suck it.
I don't know what
happened to the Pentagon,
but that shit looked like a plane.
Just hit it.
But doesn't mean it wasn't like also
there's the big theory is that it was some
sort of a remote control
plane that they've had remote
control planes since the
1960s.
We know that because they wanted to
use them in that operation Northwoods,
one of the plans involved
using a drone airliner,
sending it up in the air and blowing
it up and blaming it on the Cubans.
So if they could do that in the 1960s,
if they could blow up a plane back then,
they could probably pilot
things remote by now.
And uh,
apparently they can.
And it's been proven that they can,
they absolutely can.
They can land them,
they can take them off.
They can,
they can actually put planes in the air.
So the,
the crazy conspiracy theory
as far as I was concerned,
was that the Ma,
the one of the most fascinating ones,
they're all,
you know,
have a hint of nuttiness.
But the most fascinating once was that
there was some sort of a drone and that
that's how those planes crashed into
the buildings and that they couldn't be,
uh,
engineered,
like,
or rather the,
the people that were flying them
probably couldn't have pulled off those
maneuvers.
But that if you had it
on a remote control,
it could work.
That was where the,
some pilots had speculated,
especially like the Pentagon one,
the Pentagon and apparently pilots like
really trip out about because they've
done like these simulations and no
one's been able to recreate it in a
simulation.
You know,
they have like a simulation machine.
It shows like exactly the path that the
plane took when it hit the Pentagon and
these pilots can't even do it.
It's really hard to do so
low and the grounds down.
You've got a time itself.
It's interesting,
man.
I don't think I've,
I don't think I've seen a video where
a pilot was able to recreate it.
I've only seen failures,
but that doesn't mean that people haven't
done it just means I haven't seen it,
but it's,
uh,
you know,
that's possible.
I,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't put it past any
nefarious organization,
domestic or foreign that
they could look if they,
if they're,
well,
if anybody's willing to
fly planes into buildings,
are they?
Yes.
Clearly we saw it happen
somehow or another.
That was somebody's idea.
Okay.
Those planes that flew
into those buildings,
they didn't just fly in on their own.
Okay.
So for sure somebody
piloted planes the building,
why
would we think that they
wouldn't do it remotely?
Why would they,
you know,
we,
we are,
we really,
truly convinced that people
piloted them themselves.
I think it's a really tough to be sure
that someone is going to fly a plane into
a fucking building.
It's really tough to be sure
you can hope they do it,
but it's better to be safe.
And the way to save is get them to do it.
Tell them I'm going to do it.
I just wire the whole thing.
I'll just,
we'll do it ourselves.
So in case they check it out,
check it out,
man.
You might like fucking one more pass.
One more pass.
We'll go around again.
I'm gonna go around again.
Keep those passengers out of here.
Like you might get close then pull up,
pull up.
You know that crazy Guy John Lear.
Yeah.
He's like one of the craziest dudes ever.
He's hilarious though.
The shitty sentence.
He'll say the craziest shit.
And I heard his take on that and he said,
you know,
he is a CIA pilot.
He said,
and you know,
he's the craziest motherfucker out there.
He's probably a disinfecting agent.
Told him he,
if anybody was one that do,
there'd be a CIA shit,
say like a billionaire or some point.
He was uh,
his,
his dad owned Leer jets and he was,
uh,
as far as him being a pilot for the
CIA and being a highly decorated pilot,
he's got like records and shit.
That's all true.
But he says crazy,
crazy shit.
He says that there's no way that someone
could have hit that tower without
practicing because you're going so fast
that you would have to take a couple
rounds and time.
He said you'd have to look at a building
and go well and that building hits
after be right here and it takes a
couple of passes to nail a building cause
you're going so fast.
That's what he said.
But he could be full of Shit and I dunno,
I dunno anything about being a
pilot but that's what he said.
Yeah.
I don't imagine that they will leave it
to chance if they do have remote control
things that they get put on airlines.
I would imagine that
it would just do that.
That would be the way to do it.
You know like the latest shit coming
out on the conspiracy theory has been
looking at all this fishy shit.
Now the latest shit is like what
companies and securities companies and
brokerage and like tying it into the
collapse of Russia when Russia was
collapsing,
all these shady ass people high up,
I don't know what you want to call them
or buying up all this Russian shit and
laundering it through securities.
Like oh $250 billion of securities.
Like they were just snatching,
they made a cash grab in Russia.
But it was all illegal laundering
shit and every 10 years,
every 10 years like that was,
that was in 1991 so 2001 was the
year that they had a review that,
you know,
it takes 10 years,
it review and make sure everything,
all the securities to make sure
they're all legit and all that shit.
I really don't know how it runs,
but they're tying it into,
they had a blow up,
the security broke,
it broke ridges on the building because
that recommend checking that we're going
to find out like George w Bush's Dad,
what does he,
George Herbert Bush or he like,
it was all CIA international banker shit.
And it all ties into
the collapse of Russia.
And this is why weed is illegal.
These kind of conversations
because when you smoke weed,
go to,
it was hauled tied in man.
It's crazy shit.
Like who knows what's real or not,
but it seems like tying
it all together now,
the craziest one.
And I,
you know,
I try to be as open minded
as I can with these things,
but if you don't admit
that this one's nuts,
I think you're crazy.
And that's the Donald Rumsfeld one.
When Donald's Rumsfeld came on television
on September 10th and told everybody
that there's this real
issue with missing money,
there's trillions of dollars,
but they're going to
get to the bottom of it.
220 trillion,
230 trillion or something.
Who knows what the number was?
It was 100 trillion.
1 trillion.
That's a fucking,
that's a lot of money.
Yeah,
but they,
uh,
they,
the,
the very area where they were working on
this and the accounting offices was hit
by the
playing.
Yeah.
And this is on youtube,
Rumsfeld making that it's on youtube.
Donald's run felt saying that,
you know what?
The real enemy is here,
here in our country,
and we're going to get
to the bottom of this.
Apparently there's 213
trillion plus the money.
That number was that.
We're going to get to the bottom of it.
The enemy is here in
the Pentagon next day.
They blow up the accounting office and,
and apparently the naval intelligence
they were on to what was going on this
covert laundry and skiing
with through securities.
So like,
uh,
most of the people that died
in the Pentagon where all
the accountants and a lot
of all the high ups in the
naval intelligence because
naval intelligence was
actually looking into these securities
and these Russian so that a blow and the
naval intelligence course tower seven.
Yep.
The crazy,
one of the craziest things is that the
government investigates the government
like the,
this whole thing with
his general Patraeus.
Do you know how this happened?
The guy got,
he got busted having an
affair and he had to resign.
It's because the FBI was
investigating the CIA.
Like they investigate each other.
Yeah.
Like they,
the FBI listened to a
complaint by this woman.
She calls the FBI and says that this
other woman sending her harassing letters.
And so she,
they read the letters and
then they go back and forth.
The whole thing.
Hilarious.
This is a government was
spying on the government.
So they,
they,
these motherfuckers,
it's so addictive to them.
To like spy on people and bus people.
Bull apparently shade don't
like the FBI and the Dea,
the DEA and the FBI are like
Kinda together and the CIA,
they're separated.
Wow,
that's crazy.
Well then there's the NSA,
you know,
that's,
that's where it gets really squirrely.
Like ooze or what is that?
What's going on in,
there's so many of these fucking things
and this is some shit that Kennedy was
scared of in the 1960s Kennedy was
saying in the 1960s we have a shadow
government.
You know there's like what
that when he got into office,
I bet it was like why a big crazy ass
shadow government running things and then
you get a guy like Obama in place.
It's like this is our
last hope or rational,
sensible guy that looks like us.
It seems like that was a good one.
I wonder if that's what
it is or if it's a he get,
he just can't really doesn't
have the power change.
Now that is the trick.
The trick is he has no power.
No,
just trying as much as he can
to sort of slowly turn the tide.
But that the people that
are in positions of power,
they've done it this way for so long
and that's what's really fucked up about
it.
The idea that these guys
got away with it like this.
You know what's crazy is tower six.
There's tower one tower to tower
seven tower one two and seven.
They implode and they fall at free fall
speed tower six and tower for just had
massive bomb explosions
and debris falling on it,
but bombs exploded and it bombs.
It's bombs exploded.
And six,
I never heard this man.
There's so much and bombs and car sex.
Yeah.
Bottle.
You gotta be careful though
because people make shit up.
I haven't heard anything about bombs.
Go to go to nine one
one conspiracy nine 11.
I'm sorry that but a nine 11 conspiracy.
Not going to get me.
I'm not doing it.
Okay.
I don't have the time.
There's no,
I mean you don't think a
bomb went off and tower sex.
Um,
I didn't hear what if they did though.
Let's just say what if it did and this
is the story of a bomb went off and
tower.
There's pictures and goody outlets.
How can that be crazy when you,
you're bashing the
government all the time,
but then a bomb goes off
in tower six and nine.
I think those are fine.
I think that there is,
uh,
amongst,
especially amongst people on the Internet,
there is a very real desire to uncover
hidden secrets and sometimes it gets so
far that they reached the
bombs went off everywhere.
Maybe I believe it's possible.
I've seen the testimony,
well I think there was also explosions
and it might not have been bombs because
there were so many fires.
I mean that was one of the,
uh,
the excuses they use for tower seven.
The only one that makes sense is that
there was diesel fires because they had
diesel generators and they,
apparently they had just a fuck load
of diesel and that shit caught on fire.
And if,
if that was the case,
I could see it like gutting the place
with some crazy fire and maybe it falls
down.
I was like,
I'm not writing,
but wouldn't it be weird if it,
if it was true,
you're saying maybe it is,
maybe it isn't.
You're not saying definitely
it doesn't cause you know,
you wouldn't say that.
So maybe let's just say a bomb did go
off and there's pictures and video of it
looks like a,
the Oklahoma City bombing that building
and the office that was bombed was the
El Dorado Task Force,
which investigates all of these securities
and the money laundering and all that
shit.
Never investigating the
whole Russian collapse.
There was a lot of shit.
It was a covert economic operation and uh,
and there it was being investigated.
I mean,
how
many people would have to be
involved in something like that?
And they blew that office up there
was at that office and tower six,
it wasn't even Taiwan.
A bomb goes off and tower six.
It was that off.
They just blew it up.
Or do you think would have to be
involved in something like that?
How would they,
how would they do this?
Would they do it through emails?
Yeah,
according to this theory.
Okay.
According to this theory,
I don't know what's true or not.
I'm just reading these things.
According to this theory,
it was all about they had to get rid of
these brokerages and the people naval
intelligence and the Eldorado task force
because they were about to investigate
at the 10 year cause
our 10 years securities,
whatever that means.
They're like bonds or something or CDs
or something worth over 240 million.
That's what the investigation was about.
They finally,
we're going to,
uh,
there's still only like AIG is,
is,
oh,
supposedly according to this theory,
Aig,
that insurance company will,
they're more than just insurance.
Like they're involved in all,
they got CIA ties and all this crazy shit.
They had to cover it up.
They had,
this is according to this theory,
they needed a blow all that shit up so
there's transactions could slide through
during the chaos and they wouldn't because
the Federal Reserve at nine one one,
they,
uh,
they took executive like emergency power.
So that day they took emergency parts
so they can do whatever they want.
The security and Exchange
Commission they did.
They had an emergency um,
uh,
procedure that they've never done before,
which meant that we got
a lot of chaos here.
Let's just run all the securities
without checking them and just run these
through Pam.
That's what they did.
So that's a theory.
Who knows if it's true but it
sounds pretty fucking crazy.
I don't know if he did that.
So I think speculating about us but
what I do know is that a lot of people
banked on those airlines fucking up and
they like it's sold allow their shares.
Like they knew some things were going
at like huge significant numbers on
American Airlines.
They shorter their stocks is that alone.
It's like really squirrely.
Like let off fuck that.
That alone,
if it is true and
apparently it is that the,
I feel like that should be like a big
point of investigation and if it is true
and I've seen it reported in multiple
supposedly valid websites that the deal
with the news,
if that is true,
like this is just the fact that
that hasn't been investigated.
It makes you just go,
how many is meant cradle?
How many people can be involved in it if
we really have a really crazy sort of a
fake democracy and they're just stealing
and engineering shit and blowing shit
up on occasion taken people have to be
involved and how come nobody wants to rat
him out?
How come nobody wants to make like the
ultimate book from the shadows and then
they're going right to Afghanistan,
taken all the heroin.
C'Mon gangsters,
dude,
it's amazing.
It's so,
everyone just accepts.
It was so amazing.
It feels fake.
But I think that part of the thing is
that they did it this way for so long that
that became how you did things
and then when the came along
and all of a sudden people go,
wait a minute,
what the fuck are they doing?
They can do that and they could do this.
Like who would have found out about the
national defense authorization act and
the indefinite detention of American
civilians without right to trow.
Who to found out about that?
If it wasn't for the Internet,
of course you wouldn't
have found out it from CNN.
You don't even find out about
it from cnn.com when people say,
when people say,
Oh,
where do you get your information?
The Internet,
like what are you go fucking libraries
when going to go to fucking lie.
You go to the library,
you're fucking 12,
you're going to the library,
you go,
you go on your computer,
dumb ass.
Everyone gets their
information from the inner,
well,
that's where it gets really weird though
because you've got to make sure that
you really trust your sources.
So there's like,
there's some sources that you know,
like man,
you know,
like,
like there's like in England they
have the daily mail and now they're,
those motherfuckers were right.
Anything,
you could get an article and it's from
the Daily Mail and you've got to go,
uh,
wait a minute.
The Daily Mail,
shit,
it might be real,
but it might be bullshit.
Listen to amber lions.
You know,
we have proof through amber lines.
We have proof.
Did everything we see on CNN.
You got to question it.
You got to question everything.
You can't ever trust the government.
Well,
it's a businessman.
They're running a show.
Those new shows,
they check them for ratings.
They want to make sure that people are
tuning in and if they're not tuning in to
replace a girl and move a guy and
do this or do that to amber lions,
that it's more than that.
It's not just about ratings,
it's about their certain shit.
They fucking say,
well this is what I'm saying.
It's a business.
And you know,
if you're in the business of of news,
there's only way,
the one way you get access to that news.
You know,
you have to be able to go to countries
you have to be able to do as soon as you
like,
piss those people off.
They,
you can't get in there anymore.
You're done.
[inaudible] removed from this.
So he can't go to Congress
anymore like this.
People to this day,
I'm sure that have websites or what
people that you know want to get press
passes for certain things.
They want to be able to get into areas
where the New York Times and the Wall
Street Journal get to
and they can't get in.
Just because you have a website,
there's a million hits a day.
It doesn't mean that they're
going to let you into the,
you can't like lob questions at the
president just because you have a big
antenna,
but it really should be that way.
I mean,
if a guy has a big antenna
that means like Perez Hilton,
she'd be able to ask the
president questions then why not?
Perez Hilton's got millions
of fucking hits every day.
Why not him?
I'm asking him feel like he would have
probably questions more along the lines
of how I would think that a lot of these
fucking Weirdos that you see that he'd
get elected to Congress and
get elected to the Senate.
Well you like,
like,
like that dude that was
trying to be a president,
Paul Ryan,
the dude was running for vice president.
That's silly bitch.
Did you pay attention to
him and all pay attention?
Oh my goodness.
The Mitt Romney guy.
Yeah.
Well his,
his running mate.
First of all,
he was,
he lied about like how fast
he could run a marathon,
like you said,
around American man,
like a three hour plus sub
sub four hour marathon,
which apparently is like world class.
Like you have to be like a serious fucking
athlete to be able to run a marathon
in under four hours and then
he changed it afterwards.
Like days.
I was like six hours.
One hour.
Yeah.
They probably picked him
because he was terrible.
They call up,
get it get wasn't it Paul Ryan?
Well,
he's a good speaker.
He's a good speaker and a,
he was pretty charismatic.
The real problem is under the really
bright lights he folded and the really
bright lights.
He just bullshitted a little too much.
Got a little too cocky,
some shit that you get a set in Idaho.
He got away with it on the local news.
You really can't get away with that
shit when it's on Fox News and everybody
research.
What the fuck you say?
Whoever put him in that position.
I knew that about him.
Like,
oh,
it's no one else.
John Mccain.
When John Mccain,
I think,
you know,
the world is one by corporations
and Wall Street and all that.
They have all the goddamn power.
They're fucking,
yeah,
I mean when you can try to try and get
a guy like Paul Ryan into position,
they do it because it
seems like it would work.
He's going to listen to us.
He,
you know,
he's going to play ball and it'll work.
You know?
I mean that's,
that's,
but to me,
I'm just throwing this
out that who the fuck?
No,
so you're looking for a
conspiracy in the conspiracy.
I'm thinking John Mccain and Sarah Palin,
John Mccain aside,
it's like get mother.
There's no way that
dude who's about to die,
it's going to become president and
then then we put a crazy bitch as vice
president.
It almost seems like we need Obama to,
to win,
to handle all this shit took us all up.
That's,
that's one way I'm looking at it.
This is the way I looked at it.
I think that in order to get
to any position of power,
whether you're a senator or congressman,
when by the time you get there,
you got so many motherfucking
skeletons in your closet that you like.
Teddy Kennedy never could really run for
president after he drowned that girl.
And there's a lot of
shit that these dudes do.
Fuck.
Yeah,
so it's hard to find a guy who was
pretty clean and Paul Ryan pretty clean,
seems like a nice family man,
says a lot of shit about taking personal
responsibility toes the republican
line.
Look,
the guy looks,
he looks fit.
He looks like a man's man and
yet have you had done marathons,
Paul?
I did a marathon in under four hours.
He did a marathon in under four hours.
He's our guy and then they get in
there and they find out the guy's a
bullshitter.
I think it's more likely that,
but I do agree that in order
to get to that position,
they,
they got to think that they
can do something with you.
They got to think that you're going
to be able to play ball with them.
And a girl like Sarah Palin,
they went with her because they were,
they were desperate.
There was no one else.
They didn't know what
the fuck they were doing,
man.
They were trying to figure out
some way to reach women voters.
And one of the best ways is to have a
strong woman that represents women and you
know,
she represented the strongest
aspects of like a frontiers woman.
Bitch lives in Alaska.
Okay.
Just got big old titties and a gun.
Like they thought women were
going to go bananas for that,
that women and they'll go yes and that
would be enough to push them over the
top.
They would get all the women votes the
same way Obama got a lot of the black
vote.
Like a lot of people were like,
there's no way I'm not
voting against Obama.
And people got mad.
Black people got mad at other black
people that were gonna vote for Mccain.
You never saw anybody that was black
that had a fucking a Paul Ryan Shirt on,
you know?
No one had a Mitt Romney,
Paul Ryan shirt on.
That was by maybe a few dudes.
And just wanted attention.
But if they really thought it through,
there's no way they would have done that.
Just seems like a big show to me.
It seems like it's all
like a regional edition.
A big show.
Almost scripted.
Well it's a big chunk.
You know that because they don't,
they don't have any more
than two candidates.
They used to let extra
candidates in when they,
last time they did that
was with Ross Perot.
He was the last independent and
that guy fucked everything up man.
Cause he,
he got his own television show,
he took over NBC like during prime time.
He bought the time and he
went on and told everybody,
how are you getting fucked?
Told everybody what the Federal Bank is.
And he told everybody where taxes go
and told everybody that's insurmountable
debt and this is how
you've been set up and you,
and he did it on television.
And because of the fact that he had so
much money that he could get away with
doing shit that traditionally only the
Democrats and the Republicans could do.
But all of a sudden there's this
independent that's like stealing,
you know,
20,
30% of the vote and it
fucked up the whole thing.
And that's how Bill Clinton became
president because they're like,
and there you go.
That guy,
he ruined everything.
So then the commission
for presidential debates,
they changed what it takes to,
uh,
to be able to compete
at the highest levels.
Hell yeah,
you,
you couldn't,
you know,
they'll let a lot of kooks like
when you have like Republicans,
you have like 10 Republicans,
they'll let the heroin canes and that
they know Herman Cain like that dude fucks
everything.
He's got like 50 bitches on the side.
He just couldn't keep them from
bubbling up under the woodwork.
You know,
the guy who ran a,
he ran the pizza company and you see all
the different women that came out and
said he was,
he was banging them.
No,
well you can't do that
and run for president.
Like you can do that and
brought a pizza company.
He totally did it and pulled it off.
But they know certain shit like that.
They know guys like not
going to get that far.
It's a little song and dance until
they get down to the main guy.
And there was a couple of main guys and
the big main guy was this Mitt Romney
character.
Is that Sarah.
It's like it was always going to happen
the way this way and all the people that
are in place behind the scenes,
they all watch it all play out,
but it doesn't matter who wins the same
people are paying those people socially.
I think we're better off
with a guy like Obama.
You know?
I think it gives people hope.
You know,
he's a young black guy from a single mom.
You know that that makes
people feel better.
It makes people believe that hey,
you know,
maybe that racism shit is
kind of in the past and maybe,
you know,
look man,
if racism didn't stop a black man
from being president like you,
it's surmountable.
You can overcome this.
Like this is good example for the culture.
The real problem is that dude does a
lot of the same shit that pushed it.
That's the real problem.
We thought we were going to
get this dude who's like us,
but they're still using drones.
They still got Guantanamo
Bay trying to take our guns.
That's shit is predict all
that shit is ridiculous.
All that clamping down
on rights and going,
there's not,
there's not.
That's not a problem.
Put your finger in the air,
Dee Dee,
do you see revolution?
Do you see problems
in the streets?
Do you see rampant violence everywhere
and our children are unsafe now that's
not what's happening is that massive
terrorist attacks on America.
Why do you need to like
look at people's email?
Like why do you need to store
every phone call that's ever made?
Like,
no,
don't assume that everyone's fucking crib.
It'll cause in reality most people
are pretty fucking cool the most.
The vast majority of people are pretty
fucking cool and for you to ruin that
shit and take it away and take
all the fun away out of life,
just because there's a certain unavoidable
percentage of douchebags in the world
is ridiculous.
Knowing all the fucked up shit.
The government's been like people high,
high in the government.
I'm not talking about your
average congressman or anything,
but the people that are
really running shit,
knowing all the fucked up,
they shit they've done,
the JFK staff and all that
Gulf of Tonkin wouldn't.
Do you think the liberties that are,
they're taking from us on a daily basis?
You think that's part of a plan?
It just seems they're
so aggressive with it.
I think they worry about any sort of an
uprising and the best way to keep any
sort of an uprising from coming to
fruition is to nip it in the bud.
And when you're in a position of power,
especially,
it's an undeserved position of power.
If it turns out that you're using your
money to influence politicians and
you're,
you're manipulating the system in order
to gain an advantage so that it helps
your business and all that
stuff is exposed well that,
that that should be a crime.
That should be way worse
than insider trading.
That should be.
But meanwhile,
it's standard operational procedure.
And when there's any
sort of a threat to that,
they're going to try to
stop that threat in advance.
And one of the best ways to stop
that threat and advance it's fear.
Make people scared to speak out,
make people scared to act.
And one of the best ways to make people
scared is to give yourself God like
powers.
Give yourself the ability to just,
I can take this person and lock them in
that cage and never let them out ever.
And that's what the NDA says.
That's crazy.
Cause even Hitler would've got a trial.
Okay.
If we had captured Hitler and supposedly
in no Searle soldier had gone crazy and
shot him in the head,
which is probably unlikely,
they probably would have
shot him just like they did.
Kadafi right.
But if we did capture him,
they would have given Hitler a trial.
And what they're saying is you,
this average person that
they decide to detain,
they can choose to use tactics on you
that they would have used that Hitler,
they can choose to just
lock you up and definitely,
and not give you access to lawyers.
That's not good for anybody.
And that's not American.
That's not what we're
supposed to be about.
And you can't have that kind of power.
And that's exactly what's
happening in Egypt right now.
You know,
they let this new dude in in Egypt and
now 200,000 people are rallying in the
streets trying to get this guy to get out
of office because he changed the laws.
He made it so you can't arrest him.
He can't be tried for anything.
He just turned himself into a god.
He just got in there and then they went,
fuck you.
We just,
we already been through this shit.
No,
you can't do that.
They all get to the point of governing
and I think the possibility of being
overthrown by some completely new
organization is terrifying for them.
What if like the Green party all of a
sudden took off in this country and what
if it was like the Green Party became
the number one party in the country?
I mean,
look,
look how many people go to wholefoods?
Okay,
look how many people want to recycle.
Like,
what does that shit spreads would've had
spreads and all of a sudden the Green
party becomes the prominent
party in this country.
When we realize that we're poisoning our
food and poison our water and poisoning
the ocean and killing all the fish.
And if they ever did get to that position,
that would be a terrible loss
of power for the Republicans,
the Democrats and all the
corporations that support them.
If the public's opinion changed.
And people really did get behind a party
that was independent and not reliant
whatsoever on corporations,
that would be fucking terrifying
to the powers that be.
Instead of going around making billions
and billions of dollars a year,
traveled around a fat yachts,
you know,
banging supermodels and
then cut their heads off.
Instead of doing that,
you would make nothing.
You wouldn't be in power anymore.
Your corporations would have to stand up
on the merit of the products that they
sell,
not on your ability to change laws so
that you can make products cheaper and in
the meantime ruin the earth.
And that's a terrifying
thing for those fuck heads.
So what they try to do
is take away your rights,
take away your right to express yourself,
be able to come in and shut down
your website at any point in time.
No file sharing.
I don't what the fuck you're sending.
No,
no,
no.
I've got to look at that shit.
No,
no,
no.
I gotta be able to look at
everybody's email at anytime.
This is a matter of national security.
We are the government.
This is the Homeland Security Department
of security of the mothers and the
children of this country.
And I have to look at a few emails.
I'm going to do it.
God Damn it.
And that's where we find ourselves.
We find ourselves in this ridiculous
position where we're clearly being run by
fuckheads.
How realistic is Texas from actually
seceding from the nation going to happen?
There's no way it's not going to happen,
but meanwhile,
Texas doesn't give a fuck taxes.
They're supposedly constitutionally
being one of the few countries or cities
were con states states that can,
because I think technically they
view themselves as a republic.
You know,
I think maybe all other states do as well,
but from what I understood
the way they're the TX,
Texas state declaration or they're,
you know,
whatever the fuck their constitution is,
whatever the fuck that states have,
th th the defines themselves,
they define themselves slightly
different than most dates and they,
uh,
they believe that they're
their own sort of situation.
You know,
that all that shit came from Mexico
and all that was a Texas was Mexico,
California was Mexico.
I mean that wasn't that long ago.
I mean everybody Sorta Kinda
forgot about that.
That shit was not that long ago.
Yeah,
it's Mexico was like,
there was like giant chunks of
America that was Mexico and be like,
MMM,
not anymore.
No Shit.
Nope,
nope.
Sexist became this weird sort of the spot,
man.
It's Texas legal,
medical marijuana,
nay.
I say,
no,
no.
Austin's that strong enough.
No.
Austin is probably the best place,
like socially and liberally
and intellectually.
It's one of the best places
in the country and it's,
it's the best place in Texas for
like free thinking or free thinkers,
open minded people.
Um,
well read people,
people that are hip people at turn tuned
in to what the fuck is going on in the
world.
But they're surrounded by silly people.
You know,
there's,
there's people all around like the
middle of Texas and crazy places.
It's like a lot of like churches
and people are nutty and they're,
they're doing exorcisms and
it's like a sexist is a mix,
you know,
it's a mix of really quick.
Like Houston's really cool
at Dallas is really cool.
It's a mix of like a lot of really cool
spots and the spots when you drive to
the really cool spots and you go through
hours and hours of these backwoodsy
type towns and you're like,
Whoa,
what have you were born here?
What if you were born there?
And Eddie Bravo had to grow up.
They're like,
oh my God.
Like there's a lot of spots that soc,
and the problem is those
people get devote too.
So shit like medical
marijuana does not pass.
And the reason why it doesn't pass is
that civilization hasn't spread through
the entire state.
It's only in pockets of intensive course.
Yeah,
I'm sure they've tried.
I'm sure someone's picked him.
Forgive me if I'm wrong,
but I'm sure someone's tried to come
up with some sort of legislation,
but it's never been like
officially on the ballot.
I don't know.
I'm,
but I know that it,
uh,
it just lost in Oregon,
which was pretty surprising,
but it might sometimes it's the way the,
the,
the language is written on the law.
Like sometimes they get
stupid with the language,
you know,
and you can flip 16 year olds,
they throw something in,
be
nice just to come back.
I don't know what the
language of the law was,
but I would've thought Oregon,
you know,
be in Portland and all that.
You know,
Portland is pretty fucking hip.
That's,
that's uh,
one of the spots I would live.
I would live in Portland if I,
if I had to,
for some reason to get out of California.
Portland is a good spot.
The very cool people
at things a lot though.
Rain's like a motherfucker
drove Salami back.
It's back to La.
Oh yeah.
Really?
He's been back for maybe four months.
Motherfucker and when I see him I'm
going to shake him like a bad baby.
Cause when I,
when I talked to him up there,
I was like,
what's it like?
I really digging it.
He goes,
yeah man,
that's awesome.
I go to is the rain?
Everybody goes,
no,
not at all.
Fuck it.
He goes,
just so cool up here.
It doesn't bother me.
I got some events and Motherfucker,
I got c.W is a,
is that a chemical
thing?
Like do we need that
chemical from the sun?
Like in order to feel happy?
I've never lived in a place
where it rained all the time.
Have you done that now you've all
your southern California whole life.
Yeah.
I think there's,
there's a gray that happens in Boston
for a few months during the winter that
dulls the happiness of the
people and it's palpable.
You can sense that shit in the air.
When the gray is there,
the gray of the January gray,
the February.
Occasionally you get a
nice sunny day like wow.
Beautiful Day to day,
step outsides three fucking degrees.
That shit.
That shit wears away at you man.
Salami made up a good story and I was
wondering about that man because people
will always bullshit you about that.
They'll never tell you like,
what's it like up here man?
You like it.
Well,
I like it a little,
but man,
I get depressed as fuck in
the winter and I'm thinking,
I don't know man.
Maybe there's a bad idea.
It's awesome.
I love it.
It's the best choice.
I made the best choice,
man.
I'm so happy you should move up here to,
this is the fuck mother fuckers would try
to convince you and to moving up there
and when you move up there and go,
man,
I'm just getting depressed in the winter.
I don't know what to do.
Thinking about going back to Arizona,
what did his testimony influenced me?
Yeah,
son of a bitch.
They didn't even make it.
He had a school up there,
right.
It wasn't he running a 10th planet
because he has his black pot now.
He has a black belt in the G.
Does he really under that?
Oh Wow.
Salami.
Such a good dude.
Oh,
he's a friendly guy,
man.
Even if he's a lying
motherfucker about the climate.
Maybe he liked it initially and
then it just wore down on them.
I think.
Yeah,
I think especially if
you live in California,
it would be really hard to go to a place.
It rained all the time.
Really?
The rain sometimes.
Well,
the one thing that it's amazing
for is the vegetation God,
their forests out there.
When you go,
if you've ever been on a hike,
like through the Pacific rain forest,
you ever been like,
no.
Walk,
walked around.
Like if we go to the redwood forest,
ever do that?
Maybe as a child you got to do that.
Then at the same thing,
redwoods the,
I don't think so.
I think sequoia is a different thing,
but they're,
they're huge too,
right?
It's not the idea as a kid,
but the those forests,
man,
those crazy like rain forest and like
Washington stay where it rains constantly.
Dude,
that that's a different feeling when
you're walking through that kind of life.
Like there's so much vegetation life
around you that as you're like you're,
you're in that there's like
this bright green forest.
You kind of understand where all the
old myths of like fairies and elves and
would sprites appearing because as you're
walking there's so much energy in the
air that you're almost thinking someone's
watching you the almost looking at
trees and shit and thinking their period
at you and looking back at you because
you're feeling,
you're sensing that
there's other life there.
You're sensing it because there's
this incredible wealth of vegetation.
It fucking rains every day.
The grass is glowing green.
I mean the glass,
the grass and Oregon is like neon green.
It's beautiful.
Like just looking at the grass was like,
wow,
I never fucking saw grass
like that in studio city.
That grass is dry and gray and all fucked
up and brown that Portland grass is
alive.
And if you walk into those woods,
man,
there's something about those dense rain
forest that give off this weird sort of
feeling cause it's strange
silence and you hear animals.
But like the sign,
it's a weird sound because there's so
much vegetation that it's like being in a
room that's like stuffed with things.
Like there's not little sound
doesn't travel the same way.
It's not like being in a place where
you're on top of a hill and you overlook
canyons.
No,
you're walking through this dense thing
that feels like you're inside of a
living thing.
And it is that rain forest
is like a living thing.
In fact,
the Pacific rain forest has the biggest
single organism on the face of the
earth.
There's a mushroom colony and the
Pacific northwest that's so enormous.
It's bigger than like x
amount of blue whales.
It's huge.
And it's this connection,
like almost like a,
um,
like a neural connection underneath the,
like in the,
the way it's worked in,
in the ground,
um,
in the,
in this entire area,
load a mushroom,
but it's one giant organism here.
I better Google this because there's,
it's a,
it's very hard to describe it.
Like a giant mushroom.
Yeah.
Well it'll take bites out of it.
No,
but there's a fuck load
of mushrooms up there,
man.
You hear about those people that
died in la or California recently.
A bunch of people are dying
from eating poisonous my shirt.
There's a lot of people
that try to like go,
like hunting for edible mushrooms.
It's like a hobby with a lot of people
because you can find like some delicious
mushrooms in the wild.
But if you're all get high just to,
you know,
just to eat.
But if you're old and
you can't see this cook,
Cook.